welcome guys to the opening day of the
2021
grand chess tour held here in bucharest
romania
behind me is the heaviest building in
the world
the palace of the parliament the house
of the parliament
of romania today we have some amazing
chess players 10 of the best
in the world competing for one of the
most coveted titles
of the year
[Music]
[Music]
let's go to the studio and start the
action with yasser maurice
and alejandro welcome
to romania and welcome to the 2021
grand chess tour what a beautiful place
to get us started
with the first stop of this year's tour
it's classical chess and i am grand
master alejandro ramirez here with
grandmaster yasir sarawan
yes sir alejandro it's so good to be
with you and maurice
hello everyone welcome to st louis and
the start of the grand chess tour we
are in the opening day and the first
round is going to get started
very shortly but let's take a look at
our roster
of players alejandro and what a
star-studded roster we have for you
look at those ratings look at those
names headlining of course it is fabiano
caruana
but check it out very closely followed
by mvl maxima cheryl agrav
wesley so who's really put his foot down
this year he has been a tremendous force
in online chess can he do it offline
we'll take a look
classical players look at them alexander
grishchuk levona rhodian
shakuriya mamadyarov and taymur rajabov
anishkiri he's impressed me this year as
well
absolutely winning the champions chess
tour great finishes
in viken say a strong candidates
tournament at least the second half
and they're being joined by local
superstars not to be underestimated look
at those
ratings certainly not top 10 in the
world but
capable very capable grand master
constantine lupulescu
and young grandmaster pogba and daniel
dak
looking to make their mark in this event
let's take a look at the format we have
a 10 player round robin single round
ramen they will play
each other once 90 minutes for the first
40 moves
classical chess for sure 30 minutes for
the rest of the game
a 30 second increment all throughout an
absolutely
no draw offers doesn't matter if it's
moved 30 40 70
you gotta play it out until king vs king
or a repetition
normal traditional scoring system one
point for a win
half a point for a draw and no points
for a loss
and yasser what a prize fund
very generous indeed alejandra 325 000
to be distributed over 10 players
let's take a look at the schedule first
round of course is about to start
and they'll have a round every day
except for thursday june 10th that'll be
the rest day for the players and for
us but besides that one round a day
ruling tough you're playing
no easy opponents in this tournament wow
what to say
this has been an amazing wait i am so
excited to get started
but to take a look at the headliners of
this tournament we have of course
grand master maurice ashley thanks
alejandro
well indeed the grand chess tour is back
in business after a year hiatus because
of the pandemic
everyone's excited to see the tour begin
again
and i'm sure no one more excited than
these players
just simply amazing time to start once
again and we see the top players there
you showed that list but people are
going to be paying attention to
a special threesome the top three
players
in universal rating and let's begin
with the fabulous one fabiano caruana
the number two player on the planet we
know he could get it done
without any question he's been on the
tour since 2015
but his highest finish is only third
2016-2018
that is shocking if you will like
incredible
given how amazing this player is we saw
him
do that seven in a row feat to start a
sink field cup with the best
of the best playing we've seen him win
the u.s championship
we've also seen him contend against
magnus carlson himself
for a world title so this player can
beat
anybody hands down will he be able to
bring his top form
to this event another player who'll be
looking for his top form
is maxime vashi lagrave he is
one of the world's elite of course he's
had multiple appearances
since 2015 as well and he's finished
second twice
so close oh so close but not quite there
yet
can he get it done well everybody knows
he's dangerous the wily frenchman
tactical ideas just seem to come out of
his fingertips
with ease he will be a difficult
opponent to defeat
watch him keep your eye i'm sure all of
france is rooting
for their man and finally grand master
wesley soh
one of the best players on the planet to
be sure but not only that
his highest finish in this event is
actually 2016. he won the whole thing
no question about it he can get it done
without
any question and his talents are broad
he's not just good at classical chess
he's great at rapid and blitz as well
he's even great at online chess wait a
minute even chess 960 he defeated magnus
carlson
the universality of his style is very
difficult to pin down
and he's so solid as well that he's a
difficult man to beat
these three players you got to keep your
eyes on them because
any one of them could win of course
there's the argument for other players
like well we could win two
and to tell us more about the flavor of
what's going on
in romania we'll jump to our colleagues
christian and elmira
thank you maurice and welcome everybody
to bucharest romania
the host of the first leg of their 2021
grand chess tour the super bad
chess classic my name is christian
kirilla and i'm joined by my co-co-host
almiraz kripchenko yesterday we had an
amazing day at the opening ceremony
all the eyes were on our 10 protagonists
the 10 chess players
that are about to battle on the
chessboard but there was also one
gary kasparov making an appearance it
was a very very
exciting day but today it's all about
the chess moves
that we're about to see on the
chessboard almira what do you
look for today well first of all hello
christian hey guys
i'm so glad to be part of this legendary
commentary team
yes sir i missed your stories i'm
looking forward to hearing
more of them and it is such a special
feeling for me to be back in romania
after such a long absence actually
when i was a kid i went here my very
first international tournament and i
still remember
like the joy when i received the trophy
so this made me thinking that
you know the world of sports is filled
with outstanding achievements records
but it's also filled with
stories you know written by local heroes
and these stories
are inspiring for us so i think that
it's very important that the grass chest
tour offers the
unique opportunity for the local players
to rise up to the challenge and to face
the chess titans
absolutely i'm very very excited to see
what these romanian players are going uh
to do over the chessboard but also what
these top chess players are going to do
over the chessboard
an electrifying atmosphere here in
bucharest guys
back to you in the studio thank you
elmira and christian we'll look forward
to your
inside commentary but as we get started
let's take a look at the pairings
what's it matter what's in store for the
first games let's take
a look and you can see it starts with a
bang
mama dyarov against wesley saw an
aggressive attacking player against an
ultra solid player especially with the
black pieces in wesley
we have a classical matchup these guys
have played each other so many times
they just played each other
in the candidates alexander grishard
against maxine vasher lagrave
meanwhile a relatively unknown match up
there uh
bogdan dayak will be playing with the
white pieces against anishigiri a strong
2600
young very hungry for results
as we see wesley there getting ready for
his game
and he's certainly a very well prepared
player but with the black pieces will he
push for a win
will he just try to be solid a tough one
here when you have such a rating gap
raja both will be playing against fabio
carrada two of the absolute best players
in the world
we know rajabov's story there in the
candidates
uh we'll see if bobby with the black
pieces wants to push that one
and local legend lupulesco he has been
around the chess world
for many many years he'll be playing
against world legend
levon aronian again aronian the higher
rated player you can see
a little bit of a pattern today pirated
players playing with the black pieces
today almost out of coincidence
but which ones will take a risk which
ones
will push because remember you gotta
score those points against the
local players meanwhile the local
players are saying
my opportunity to shine in the sunlight
and i'm thinking about daniel the local
player
he was a child prodigy absolutely one of
the youngest grand masters
and yet somehow he didn't emerge right
he was
is really really a big talent do you
know a little bit inside what happened
to him or didn't happen to him it's the
case maybe
i don't know him too well i have seen
him in many tournaments he is a very
focused player
shows his emotions on his sleeve you can
see him there
the young grandmaster from romania a
last-minute addition to the tournament
we have to emphasize that
he likes his preparations plentifully
but he
replaced richard report a full grand
chest to her participant
almost at the last minute just a couple
of days ago richard unfortunately got
sick not covet
but did uh fall late yeah he
had a high fever and was unable to
participate as you can see
some security traditional security
measures make sure nobody's cheating in
this event no metal allowed
and the players are starting to get
ready and we should have the opening
move
in almost no time and we are told that
gary kasparov
is going to be one of two player two
persons i should say
to make ceremonial opening moves uh gary
of course uh teaming up with the
kasparov.com
and the organizers of the grand chester
we'll be talking more about what uh
gary's up to as the round unfolds there
he is
speaking of him there he is caspar look
at that energy i'm sure that he's
desiring to be back there i know let me
in let me play let me play boy i
what you were just saying about richard
by the way being the last
minute replacement i mean
let's take a listen to the
a great piano it is the first show
we introduce again the players who are
playing today
in the order of their rating fabiano
caruana
[Music]
it is our pleasure to have a ceremonial
first move actually two
ceremonies on the first move for this
first day so i
invite for the center table and our
cargo
[Applause]
yeah i do actually but the question i
had of course was that gary born in baku
did he speak with him at in azerbaijani
uh what move do you want to
make timor or did he speak to him in
russian or did he speak to him in
english
so many choices exactly and there we
have our
other guest of honor and that is
legend of football and coaching football
and did he do a good job with his e4 as
well so i i think
i think lupulesco will be happy with
that choice okay very good
again i just have to say uh thank you uh
to everybody in our audience for joining
us
the excitement here in studio in st
louis has
just been great we've been anxiously
waiting for
over 15 months to return to the chess
club here in st
louis and boy what renovations are also
taking place
here at the st louis chess club it's
just great to be back oh it's absolutely
great to be back
in the studio with you guys i just can't
wait for the
games to get started exactly give me
some meat
for sure uh maybe we can first take a
look at the
money distribution of the tournament
remember this is the grand
chess tour so they are also playing for
the tour points
there will be several stops in this
year's
uh tour we're starting here we're moving
on to paris almost immediately
after super bad chess classic take a
look at the price
thousand dollars there for first place
very very nice
and also those gct points remember if
you win the tournament without the need
of a tiebreaker
you get 13 points if you win with a
tiebreaker you get
12 points and then it goes down the list
yasser that is a lot to play for
it sure is there are five events of
course and the winner of the grand chess
tour
the player accumulates the most gets a
hundred thousand
dollar bonus marie that sounds pretty
good to me
share it amongst the commentators
[Laughter]
as well well the games have begun we do
have liftoff folks and an interesting
pattern
as we have seen if you watch a lot of
the online action
that's been taking place in the
champions tour you see a lot of e4
e5 e4 e4 e4 best buy test you think
e4 is the only move you want to play
okay sometimes they mix it up but it's
just
large percentage e4 but guys take a look
at these games
we had in timur's game d4
to start chakriar's game no surprise d4
to start
in the game with gristrok versus vashila
grav a grunfell coming again
out of d4 we see this position
also from lupulescu this began
as d4 as well queen c2 nimzo and
finally another game with dayak versus
geary what
what's in the water everybody's decided
d4 is the way to play
well there you go i mean d4 move i over
i've been playing along with the english
so these guys
they just decided let's not have any
berlin
let's take a look at the top match-up of
course
against fabiano caruana they're playing
a regozen variation with bishop b4
yeah one of the most theoretically sound
lines for black against the system
i have to say it's not it has not been
the flavor of
the year the ragosan hasn't really been
seen that much
this year right but like many things in
just
mostly out of fashion there hasn't
really been a refutation there hasn't
really been any variation that's given
that much trouble
to black with the ragosan which starts
with this move
bishop b4 of course black has other
moves in this position
uh you can go transpose it to the semi
slot with c6
they have super sharp vienna with d
takes c4
you can play more classically with
bishop e7 that was very popular a few
years ago hikarna
using it all the time in the world
championship match between fabi
and uh magnus but bishop b4
the ragosan as you were saying bishop g5
i've always considered this the most
challenging way for white to meet the
rugosa and you can do other things
queen a4 check at one time was popular
e3 bishop f4 but
bishop g bishop g5 and the players
seemed to
well actually timor just stopped after
the move h6
perhaps a little bit of a surprise as i
was saying not the most
common way to deal with this setup
nowadays
of course everybody at this level has
studied it deeply
but five hasn't played a region in a
while that i can remember
perhaps tamer considering his options
trying to think
what to do in this position of course he
could take on f6 he could
uh play bishop h4 they'd lead to
completely different types of positions
uh bishop h4 can lead to extremely sharp
stuff
g5 94 ideas are immediately on tap
they're not necessarily good but you can
think about that exactly
exactly as you say uh leads to a
very different uh and very sharp game
compared to let's say the more tepid
waters
that you could expect after bishop takes
f6 queen it takes f6 and maybe
we could update the board on the left
because that is not a team or a job of
game
that is actually a game
with uh that is luke lets go against our
onion
with the queen c2 so we can move on to
that game since we are going to leave
taymor think about that one
let's take a look at he does take on f6
actually i'm not surprised
about that because it's a more solid one
let's take a look at the lupulescu
against levon
aronian game okay when we left it we saw
we just saw the opening with the queen
c2 classical nimzo indian and after
castles
knight f3 okay i liked the
i like to play the classical myself as
white
but i almost always played bishop g5
in this position and i and i did it for
very specific reasons
i didn't like knight f3 because of the
way lavone has played
with knight a6 and this move knight c
knight c5 to e4 always bothered me as
white right i felt like i i wasn't going
to get anything
out of this opening now maybe
as we know uh opening theory of marches
forward
it does but i actually like this
approach from lupulescu
it's a very solid approach it leads to
positions where maybe you don't have
that much
but you have a little bit of an edge
it's a little bit safe you're playing
against a player that's higher rated
might try to beat you
and you might get to a position where
you say well
it's really not that special for black
it's difficult to create your own
chances
while i can press more or less risk-free
of course you have this weak pawns on 3
4 and c3
but it's the activity right black has
been forced
to retreat this bishop to e7 the spit
white black
sorry dark scored bishop by white will
come to f4 we're coming to b1
a very straightforward game here for the
romanian player
lots of theory here black still needs to
prove it's his equality
but plenty against still playing in this
position whoa e4
okay well there we see it white has come
prepared and what's
caught your eye uh maurice well we
should point out that the board on the
left is not the position
the board on the right was the correct
position there
uh but we'll update that shortly and i i
love positions like this dynamic
imbalances are always great in chess
it means that somebody is going to look
that's what you look at a position you
say
looks like somebody's going to lose
that's what we like we just we don't
care who wins or loses we have no
preference
but somebody is going to lose well this
somebody what i'd like to point out this
game
is the the game you guys talked about
rajabov versus caruana
timor has never defeated fabian
classical chess
never the record is 4-0
fobby he's just beat him every which way
silly and timor despite having white
multiple times as many as seven times in
their matchups i believe they played 12
games and seven times
timor has had white and has yet to taste
bobby's blood just simply he hasn't done
it he has not gotten it done so
watch out for this game as a grudge
match or at least a little bit of
high motivation which he wants to say
i've got to finally beat this guy and
prove
that i am indeed one of the elite elite
of the chess world well we know it
already timor
but fabi is not buying in he's like no i
own you so we'll see
whether or not that trend continues or
will t won't be able to break
that curse what an interesting stat
actually rajabov
a very solid player he goes through
tournaments undefeated
exactly while not winning a game right
so maybe winning one
maybe on that plus one yeah but fabi
seems to be a tough customer for him
yeah sometimes it's just the way uh
these match-ups work
going to the game of a shack versus
wesley so
this is what makes wesley such a wily
customer
when you're playing against wesley he is
just a very broad defensive repertoire
and the queen's gambit accepted has
always been a part of that repertoire
he uses the queen's gambit accepted but
he picks his spots right
and with shaq who we know is an ultra
aggressive player he's basically said to
shaq
go ahead i invite you to play these
knight c3
e4 double edged variations i'm prepared
for you
and shaq goes he ducks the challenge
with the move e3
and uh reverts back to a very
traditional queen's gambit accepted
position
that quite frankly has been played
thousands of games and again you can see
where obviously mamadiara comes prepared
to the game but wesley not employing
perhaps his most
usual type of systems and mahmoud
thinking i think how do i want to
approach this this is
what we call the tabiah the starting
position of the queen's gambit accepted
white has many choices in this position
as mamodiarov
contemplates his very solid ultra solid
taking on c5
uh as we have a lot of different options
but before that
let's go to romania as christian has
some updates for us
well uh updates yes i'm just a little
bit confused about
what mvl is doing in uh in his life to
be honest when is he going to stop
playing the grunfeld
and the najdorf he's played it
successfully all the way up until
this past year but in the past year he's
been struggling
with it nevertheless he's once again
repeating it
in uh this tournament at least that's
how it looks like for the moment
he's playing it against griez chuck
right now with the black pieces
grieschuk actually has an
edge in their personal record three to
one against mvl
and mvl is taking a very very sharp
approach to this game
once again choosing the grunfeld very
very dangerous approach i do not
recommend it
ct xd5 knight xd5 e4 knight xc3
beat xc3 bishop to g7 this is the
typical
uh tavia position of the grunfeld white
can play in a lot of ways can play
bishop to e3
can play h4 but he continues to go with
the very standard knight to f3 c5 rook
to b1
this is a very old line which allows
black to uh gain upon
nevertheless white's initiative is quite
powerful but
it is kind of understood that if black
knows his theory
he should be able to equalize but will
mvl be
able to remember his theory let's see
castle bishop to e2
c takes d4 c takes d4 queen to a5 check
this is the moment where black is going
to win
upon because queen to d2 for example
just leads to a very very equal position
black can even play a move such as
knight to c6 defending the queen
doesn't have to exchange the queens
immediately of course you have to be
very careful
not to play in this position the almost
tempting
move d5 because this opens up diagonal
of the bishop and after bishop to c3
bye bye sayonara you can be ready to
resign
but of course white play the move bishop
to d2 not queen to d2
queen takes a2 black has an extra pawn
castle
bishop to g4 and this is uh what i'm
surprised also about krishuk he chose
this
a very dangerous and very sharp line but
after bishop g4 which is one of the main
lines in the position
he is about to spend a lot of time what
does he have planned does he remember
his theory
will he be able to put any pressure on
mvl only time will tell
guys back to you thank you uh christian
so
that theoretical dispute going on there
i'm not sure i thought christian was a
grunfeld guy i thought he would be
supporting mbl
he was but he gave it up because he
couldn't remember his lines
i hope he didn't hear me nice nice nice
we can actually take a look at that very
theoretical theoretically heavy position
that krishnak and mvl are playing
try to get into the mind of the russian
chess player because that
is a very well known situation after the
bishop g4
going back to kasparov kramnik or
kramnik kasparov
from the world championship match 2000
uh and that was the match that vladimir
won and
had some nice uh games as white in the
groom
sorry please jump in tell me uh what's
going on after this move bishop g4
the main move by far nowadays is to put
the bishop on g5
it's a dual purpose move you attacked
upon e7
and you defend the pawn on d4 which is
being targeted again because of the
threat of bishop takes f3 and let's not
forget that you keep
on tap the option of taking on b7
with that rook certainly yes certainly a
position that requires
strong care by black if i remember
correctly the only move in this position
is h6
you actually have to kick out the bishop
and tactically this is the best time to
do so
because if you take on e7 i can play the
move
rook e8 and when the bishop retreats
somewhere
uh the e4 pawn will be hanging and this
is just not good for
white his center starts collapsing
despite the fact that black is playing
without the knight
and a rook one of the more difficult
things to explain to amateur players
right
right lots of rules you can break them
when you're mvl
don't try this at home exactly these
type of variations i must say
uh that are double edged like this where
pawns are being sacrificed
the the top players in the world they
analyze them to such a great
extent after bishop g5 h6
bishop e3 what is the theoretical
um outcome last i
checked this was supposed to be equal
after a long long series of
moves forcing those yeah yeah not
terribly forcing but supposed to be the
only way to challenge black something
like knight c6
you had to go d5 if i remember correctly
then the knight jumps to a5 but you can
also take on f3 that's the other
variation and here
y usually just plays the move bishop c5
it's also the only way to keep pressure
and the game just kind of keeps going a
little bit worried about this queen
being offside but for the moment
that bishop is patrolling the diagonal
stopping rook a1
otherwise the queen will get snapped i
know that
a lot of times the tactics that white
bases
his compensation on is to try to hunt
down that queen
so that we'll keep an eye on that
another
incredibly sharp theoretical dispute
let's take a look at this one
i like this anish gary as black
challenging uh daniel the local
an anti-moscow gambit something that's
also fallen out of fashion
this is the semi slav straight up most
people are playing [ __ ] e3 seems to be
what everybody's playing nowadays
people have been shying away from the
move bishop g5 i've even seen
g3 become more popular than bishop g5 in
the last few years
right but none of that today we're gonna
be playing
ultra sharp stuff bishop g5 black has
two theoretically
sound ways of playing in this position
going into the bot phoenix system
with the ultra ultra sharp d-take c4 e4
b5 e5 this immediately becomes a mess
zx6 bishop h4 and then
something happens and 25 moves later
you're in a drawn end game
yeah it's crazy how deep the lines are
been analyzed but i do recall going back
to 2006 and the world championship
match between uh vladimir kramnik and
veswanathondanan
sorry uh with this moscow
anti-anti-moscow sorry
uh takes on on c4 e4
and g5 bishop g3 b5
and in incredible theoretical duels
vichy
won the world championship match
essentially with the black pieces
against vladimir kramnik absolutely and
we have the move bishop e2 already on
top
it is the main line of the position it's
not the only move but it is supposed to
be the most challenging
i remember one time queen c2 was awesome
two was thrived h8 was actually tried at
some point as well
exactly there's a lot of moves but the
the the top guns have settled on bishop
e2 i think it has been for a while
black's really only moved here in this
position
i think his bishop b7 people have been
experimenting i think with bishop g7 but
i don't know if it was really any good
and then knight bd7 is supposed to be a
big mistake
already it's very easy to go wrong in
this positions here the brake d5
it causes an incredible amount of
headaches for black
notice that if i ever successfully take
on b5
the c7 square might be very weak so
you got to watch out for all these kind
of things not supposed to be the way to
play of course
geary knows this theory inside and out
plays the move bishop b7
and i am curious on what variation we're
going to see oh we have an answer
bogdan has played uh the move queen c2
very quickly very quickly h4 and castle
being the main lines of the position
and let's see if he has some very nice
home-cooked meal here in this
anti-moscow
it is an excellent chance to show his
preparation he's a very well prepared
player
and i want to see what he brings to the
table here as gear is like queen
c2 yeah like scratch that one
now talk about trying to remember your
analysis and maurice you've got
some what have you got in front of us
here this is crazy
looks like a wild hot mess on the
chessboard but i'm going back to the
matchup
between team rajabov and
fabiano caruana as we said fabi has
really been spanking him over the years
with a great record and i pulled up a
game i was on my stream yesterday on
twitch
and showing my fans there this position
look at this this is just looks like
insane position
black's got a pawn on a3 white's got the
pawn all the way to b4
already this is fabi with the white
pieces roger with the black pieces
in this position and black of course is
in a bit of trouble the king
doesn't look totally exposed but it's
going to be shown in a second and it
looks like all the energy is on this
point
but i'd like to show you what happened
next in this kind of
memory kind of trauma that raja has
playing against fabi because fabi went
full lizard mode
in this position he played h4 he's like
that's it i don't care about what's
happening on that side forget about your
pawn i'm just going to come get you and
after it takes
h5 just attacked two pawns to the good
but after knight g3 was clear he had to
give back a pawn
and then a knight just cemented itself
on f6
and then f5 let's keep the attack
rolling and
this is just a blast through as he kept
going in this position now the rook on
h1 you see
both rooks attacking the knight on f6
black's pieces on the back ring
it didn't take long to for fabi to
finish him off this queen attacking the
pawn
on a2 he said okay i'm not going to give
you that either and now look at this
fantastic finish guys queen d4 bishop f5
attacking his rook on g4 what did fabi
do
i don't care about my stinking rook you
can have it you
i'll take your queen you take mine and
now this sweet move
knight to e8 nasty dropping the knight
on the back rank threatening f8 queens
and
mate you could take this white rook off
the board and the knight and pawn alone
will win you the game as i said timor
has some of these
traumatic losses to fabi this is a
full-scale
beatdown he's going to try to get his
revenge and finally beat fabi
at least one time let's see if he can
pull it off there's still a long way to
go
thank you maurice that that feels like i
got scarred
90 branded 98. you never forget a move
like that no
no that hurt that that was a very very
nice
game i want to say the players uh
in our theoretical dispute between
daniel and anish
they're they're just been snapping out
the moves
alejandro uh last move was rook d1986
knight a6 is a dutch specialty
a dutch specialty okay let's see after
the move queen c2
uh knight h5 going immediately after
this bishop on g3 this bishop on g3
really is a good bishop in the sense
that it patrols
very nice diagonal to begin with but
bishop e5
can really be an awkward move to meet in
certain positions
so knight h5 rook d1 eliminate that
bishop
and knight a6 okay i'm a little bit
thrown off by that move i actually have
experience in this position
because i prepared uh with grand master
benjamin bach one of my students from st
louis university uh against in the world
cup against ivan saric
and uh this is his position
not exactly this position sarge decided
not to take on g3 and not to play knight
a6 which is
perfectly good way of playing plenty of
sharp games have gone that way
but uh benjamin told me about this
possibility of playing knight a6
something i had never seen before
quite interesting quite a different way
of approaching the position the knight
actually
takes advantage of the fact that this
queen is on c2
it can be hit but night before in
certain locations so you can maybe force
the bishop
off with bishop d knight d3 forcing
bishop to hd3
remember the black is up upon clear and
sometimes
you return this pawn to obtain
positional compensation
it's not usually a little bit of a
headache because when it develops to d7
instead of going to a6 again it's this
loss of control over the d5 square
that sometimes allows to break d5 to
come in with too much force
whereas when the knights on a6 it
actually controls
d5 square indirectly with
the move knight before tempo and
directly with the queen
influence on the d5 square knight a6
not surprised to see it okay benjamin
buck is a dutch player
after all right okay but after the move
knight a6 since you're going to the
side of the board and i'm thinking to
myself well this knight
you're right it can go to b4 but at the
moment
that doesn't really impress me aren't
isn't anish inviting white
to well occupy the center with a move
like knight e5
in order to play bishop h5 give me the
pawn
and also maybe to open up the game with
f4
so it it is very sharp from this
position
absolutely double edged yeah for a pawn
and remember this kind of compensation
is very time-based what do i mean you
need to do something with your
initiative
very consequently very consequential
very tempo-based
if black fully develops if black is able
to safeguard his king somehow
don't only does he have an extra pawn he
has a very strong majority that will
eventually push
on the queen side and he has two bishops
yes
so he has everything going for him in
the long term of the position
it's up to dark to immediately put
pressure
on uh black there are several ways to do
that
i unfortunately don't remember what was
secret prep and what was it
okay so i can't give up too much from
this point on
to our audience you'll have to become
premier members if you want
alejandro to share everything but i mean
looking at this
looking at this position guys just just
looking at it on the board
uh there are only a few moves for white
to be
well i shouldn't say the only few there
are obviously plenty of moves where i
could play in different directions
but there are only a couple of breaks
that really come to mind right away one
break
is the move b3 no like you got to look
at the brakes whenever you look at a
position
because the pawn wall is stopping you
from getting to the other side so
you've got to somehow get in b3 is one
way at nibbling because this pawn is the
most
advanced in the position so you could
start to limbo nibble on this pawn and
see if you can create an energy there
a4 is another way you got to be careful
in that position
as well that something doesn't chase
your knight away after you play a4
and finally the move that you'd love to
play and crack
the position open is d5 if that could
work
then black's king is caught in the
middle and white's pieces hopefully can
create some action against
the black king the challenge for white
is also with your rook already on an
open file do you want a castle you want
to get your king out the middle or do
you want to tuck it to f1
and now i'll also add instead of a break
you could play for e5 and put your
knight on the e4 square
and see if you can make hay on the dark
squares unfortunately you don't have a
dark square bishop this bishop could go
to e7 and cover
all the business squares this position
is exactly what geary wants
against a lower rated player he's
figuring i'm going to outplay him
in this very complex crazy unbalanced
position sign me up because he doesn't
want anything dull and boring
and make a draw against one of the lower
rated players
in the competition this is just the
position you want coming out the gate
more than that maurice you know what i
really like in gary's position when i
mentioned this move knight a6
when benjamin mentioned it to me i had
never even heard of the idea
and look at bulkman he's like really
he's like knight a6 like come on what is
this
right that's not a good sign for him
this is not the type of position
that you want to be surprised in there
are some other positions we have today
where
if you're surprised no big deal i'll
make a move normal looking move it'll be
fine
here this is a very sharp tempo based
position we cannot stress that enough
the move knight a6 i think has thrown
him off of his preparation
i can understand why too it does not at
all
natural move to my way of thinking but
knight a6 is really
a challenge for white what other
games have we not uh delved into too
much well by the way
uh levone and
well that game's just it's the draw
right yeah i'm sorry to say that
it's just gone by so quickly but once we
we start capturing on b7 doesn't
everything just
come off the off the board probably not
the only
danger of an early drawer being told
whoa not danger
not danger inside the scoresheet yeah i
mean this is dead already
we said the cleaning lady came in and
vacuumed all the pieces off the board
when we left it we left it at this point
where we were expecting the move bishop
to g5
which is the main line and instead of
that
uh well well rook b7 is supposed to go
into an immediate draw
which i guess is what we're seeing rook
takes b7 and this is
why they don't do it yeah bishop takes
d4
e5 e5 i do remember
knight a6 has been played already before
all right and
takes on b7 88 is forced
e6 this seems to be the novelty of the
game but not a very impressive one
and we have to take doesn't even think
about it he still has more time than he
started with by the way
really okay uh almost a certain sign
that the players are still in their prep
when they have more time on the clock
than what
they're doing there we're seeing uh
i don't even know what you what grisha i
think your shirt is probably figured how
do we make a repetition now
yeah like the the rules say no draw
offers
what do we do now well you can play the
plane all you want but you cannot offer
a draw
if we play the move queen e3 i'm trying
to set up a position of
symmetry after 30 moves okay the
grunfeld lives another day
do you see what you see aronian come to
the board
and it didn't even take him half a
second he looked at it
yes indeed and here we do have a move it
looks like he's just gonna play g3
uh that doesn't matter this this
position is so dry and so dead
as you said that grunfeld lives another
day
what what do you guys think is is in
grystrich's mind
maybe he was surprised by the gruffald
wow one of the things that i i just have
to say
uh having come recently from europe
myself
uh the travel restrictions and
everything that's going on
i don't know exactly when the players
arrived
but that could be just getting adjusted
uh to the first day of play maybe what
have you said
is this the first time you guys are
noticing for me for sure that mvl was
wearing a mask he wasn't wearing
asking candidates was it no
i don't recall seeing him in a mass so
it seems almost like it's optional the
players
uh can wear a mask obviously
sasha is not well actually i don't
remember having visuals for the
for the candidates but but i don't
recall him wearing a mask and here he
is being uh potentially a bit careful i
mean every you could do it
you could do it obviously and and these
days it might be a good idea to wear a
mask
anyway for whatever you know the flu has
certainly been down as a result
of many of the sanitary uh precautions
we've been taking so
not a bad idea uh but we have a special
guest in romania
with christian carrillo
thank you alejandro yes i'm here with
elia domitrescu
a man which is probably very well known
among the romanian
fans he is a coach he is a football
superstar
and uh right now he's also a commentator
first of all elia welcome to the show
thank you very much tell us a little bit
a little bit about your experience
around the superbad
chess classics from what you've seen
yesterday at the opening ceremony
and today during the first few moves
i was impressed about the opening it was
fantastic
events i followed the
speech of gary kasparov opening speech
and he was tremendous outstanding
he managed fantastic the press
conference
when i was a kid always
elizabeth he was commented
the biggest matches between karpal
karpov and kasparov
and it's a big honor for the participate
on this event speaking of uh gary
kasparov
who was your favorite during those
matches was it gary or was it
anatoly kasparov kasparov of course
that's the diplomatic answer anyway uh
well uh tell us a little bit about
your first move you played a d4 um
do you know anything about constantine
luculescu and his partnership maybe
with that any similarities between that
and your partnership with george
during the golden years i asked him to
move what to move forward yeah i was him
before
and do you see any similarities between
his partnership with
two players to romanian players big
strategy you have to be intelligent you
have to prepare them and you have to the
match you have to be concentrate
you have to anticipate the movement of
the opponent and to react
is the same like in
[Music]
like in football like in football of
course and who is your favorite
during this event
thank you very much for joining us elia
it's a pleasure for me and for
all the romanian fans to see you on our
show thank you very much
thank you back to you guys thank you
thank you christian and
i have to say great for romania but he i
remember
was very painful for me i'm an argentina
soccer fan
right and he scored twice against
argentina when they got knocked out in
1994 and maybe i was only six years old
but i still remember that it hurt and it
still hurt
wow okay i mean football football fans
and chess fans have
long memories i'm just checking in
on the game between timor and fabby
because for me
these two players are really the
heavyweight
matchup of around one and since the
opening by the way since we've left it i
mean
it seems like we're still in theoretical
waters because
uh first of all the position's a little
bit familiar to me i've seen it before
but they're playing slowly alejandro
i would say tamer is playing slowly favi
seems to be spending just about the
amount of time that you would spend
walking around not noticing that your
opponent has moved
and then sitting down and making a move
making move quickly
it's a very well known position but
these particular variation that timur
has
employed is supposed to be harmless
actually knight
e4 is supposed to give a little bit of a
try
exactly and even the move castles has i
don't even know if that's
still the main theoretical way of
playing after the move c5 in this
position
um yeah i think castles may be still the
main line but after c takes d4
i thought i thought people are playing
94 in this position to try to get
a little bit of a something i remember
uh games of fabi where 94 was actually
employed as well and after knight takes
d4 bishop d7
there's been plenty of rapid just draws
in this position after the move queen b3
and really hoping we do not see the move
queen b3
uh and the timor actually has an idea in
this position because
the queen b3 knight c6 uh more or less
white has no choice but to take on c6
you take on c3
and everything comes off the board like
again it's what
i i feel like it was a game of wesley so
and it might have been from the
chess league where somebody played
bishop d5 bishop c4 bishop
c6 yeah exactly it was a repetition so
again
uh i have seen this uh line of play for
white
and white didn't get anything so nothing
happening yet
maurice you've got an another mind
twister
you spoke of wesley soh and everybody
knows
it's difficult to beat wesley because if
he goes
solid on you it's like running up
against a brick wall
and he's right now playing against
shakriar mamadirov
in a position that's not so thrilling
it's not one of the wild ones that we
sink our teeth into and we see wesley
they're trying to figure out
exactly what to do now they have had
incredible
experience with each other i found 69
games
in the database a lot of those rapid and
blitz they've been playing
on the grand chess store for some time
so a lot of rapid and blitz games and a
lot of online blitz games
as well and again a lot of different
results
but i wanted to show you what happens
when you mess with wesley
in this position chakra went wild from
the opening he played the bird to start
that is
f4 on move one later play 9
g4 as you see this crazy position
on the chessboard white trying to
massacre block but it's wesley sawyer
playing
and so the position continued like this
rook takes on c4 and after knight takes
e5
the rook on c4 is hanging so rook to c5
by shakri are thinking okay i'm going to
get my piece back
on e5 no doubt about it right
wrong knight to c4 a surprise hit
by wesley now suddenly he's up a piece
hitting the bishop on e3 getting ready
to move his queen the move rook takes d5
knight takes e3 you call that a fork
that's a fork
i'm hitting everybody in the position
queen to e2
knight takes f1 now the rook is hanging
on
d5 rook d7 the knight is trapped but
here comes
a rook crashing through and suddenly it
is a black
that has the extra material the game
continued queen c4 93 with a little
tickle
on f1 after queen e6 king h8 white
couldn't continue the attack because
that's mate
rook f1 is game over h3 to slow things
down but here came the other rook and
now it's pure desperation it's a mating
attack
that black has fashioned he got
desperate took on g7 try to check
but after king to h6 hanging out not
worried about g5 because of king h5 and
this white king
is about to get mauled and chakriar had
to resign
that's what happens when you mess with
wesley so and maybe while we see a
slightly more conservative approach
by shakriar in this game nice
thank you maurice very very nice finish
there by wesley what we have
in the game actually again
um in this queen's gambit accepted i
know d4 takes c5
does have its supporters they think that
they're getting something with white
i've played the queen's game and
accepted it and i think no you just
don't have an edge i think if you're
going to play
these positions as white i think you're
going to come back to bishop b3 or
queen e2 and go into one of those
isolated queen pond positions if you can
get it
but after takes on c5
it seems to me that you just
you mentioned wesley in the brick wall
well this is kind of what he's put up
he's fashioned a a brick wall until i
looked at this move knight
knight d4 and that was a little bit odd
uh peculiar i wanted to say for me how
about yourself uh
alejandro jump in if you have some
insights i am familiar with the move
bishop e2 this idea of rerouting the
bishop to the long diagonal
um the main idea as far as i remember
was to move knight bd2
and then trying to kick out this bishop
exactly relatively early
right so if you see a move like b5 for
example
yeah then you're happy then yeah you get
your knight to b3
and you hit the bishop and you hope
something like this and now you could
now you're potentially in business with
the bishop b4
check absolutely but knight d4
id4 is new to me it does prevent the
move b6 i don't actually know if it
prevents the move b6 but i'm kind of
assuming it does i suppose because
bishop f3 could be very disconcerting
not to mention that knight c6 is also a
check but bishop f3
and wesley said okay if you're playing
for bishop f3
i'll play knight e5 idea play rook d8
and maybe force an isolated queen pond
with
out queens on the board that's not a
problem um
and okay the the onus
zon white once again to come up with
something
at this moment you mentioned bishop uh
d2 trying to get on the long diagonal
maybe just directly b3
bishop b2 certainly makes sense uh i
would consider playing the move knight
b3
asking the bishop where he wants to go
uh depending if
you put it on d6 i might develop
differently if you put it on b6 maybe i
can consider the move bishop d2
similar ideas because it feels a bit
uncomfortable for black you have bishop
b4 coming knight c3 it seems easier to
develop for the white people
i'll go with that i i'll just say that
after knight b3 you kind of
forced me to put my bit you may make a
decision
declare myself so to speak and i'm
assuming assuming knight c3
yeah you're maybe eyeballing something
over here i think
i think at some point i'll go e4 and
i'll try to embarrass your pieces
because f4 will be such a big threat
e4 f4 e5 right on tap okay
maybe there's something there i would
say that of course the structure is
symmetrical and for that reason black
has good equalizing chances but i would
say that he still needs to prove it
okay fair enough and what about you
maurice what have you got for us uh
in well you know i'm looking around the
horn and
this is nuance end game it's nice you
know this one yeah
that's great that's wonderful guys tell
us what you really yeah we don't
care we don't care what we like is this
like we like the fun stuff this stuff is
wild and interesting
and you can sing your teeth into it and
after it's interesting to know what
happens when a strong chess player
gets caught in preparation that he's
never
seen before what do you do right because
you could get
really scared at a moment like this
after you see a move knight a6 and you
say
man i prepare this line and this joker
just dropped this move
that i've never seen before and the
joker happens to be a monster
named anish giri what do i do well you
could get
aggressive after a long thought and go
after something like b3 as we mentioned
uh thinking about e5 and knight e4 or
you could
maybe be a bit more conservative we see
we don't know a lot
about bogdan i know i don't know
a ton about him because he's not
normally what we cover
at the top level of chess do we want to
see his style
how he plays what does he do when he's
challenged
and here he decided i'm going to go
ultra conservative
i'm going to play a move that maybe
anish didn't study so carefully
this solid move a3 you had mentioned
alejandro that this is a tempo
based line and the move a3
is more or less a conservative i'm not
going to play quickly i know you're up a
pawn
but i'm still going to chill and relax
and make sure you don't get some play
and he said hey no problem we see that
niche
after a bit of time put his bishop on
the g7 square
and get up and walk away not very
impressed was unique
by that a3 move and making his opponent
know
uh yeah your move was not in my analysis
it looks a little crappy
and i'm just going to keep developing my
pieces and here we have
bogdan daniel diak one of
definitely one of the prodigies of
romania part of the olympic queen
born in i'm not gonna try
19 years old 19 years old 2002
absolutely his first appearance there in
the grand chester as we mentioned
replacing
grandmaster richard report one of the
best players in the world who
unfortunately got
sick just before our event started
he replaced him i thought i was it was
the act that replaced him and a very
well prepared player i do have the
experience of playing
tournaments alongside him i have never
played him directly
but you can always see that he comes
very well prepared he's very sharp
very tricky he always likes to set up
these
worth his emotions on his sleeve you can
tell from across the room if he's losing
or winning
absolutely great player great tactician
let's see if he finally has what it
takes to
hang with these 2700 guys a3 played
bishop g7 i have seen the move a3 before
mentioned in those files i had talked
about as we have a little bit of
kasparov on the way up camera
blocking
[Laughter]
keep it moving keep it moving but bishop
g okay
let's be clear for me a3
it's a move i consider and i come back
to only after my
alternatives e5 d5 knight e5 are found
wanting
i don't like it it does kill the knight
this is the big plus of the move a3
you spend the tempo but you say really
this knight on a6 where is it going
it would be okay on c7 but again
after you go to c7 where are you going
with this knight it's
not so clear however it does cost that
tempo after bishop g7 black is saying i
am just going to castle
i'm going to solidify my position and
this knight it's helping me play c5 so i
just need to move my queen out of the
way i'm going to play c5 my bishops are
going to breathe
fire on the board what does white have
to do if i remember correctly you have
to go for the move e5 take advantage of
the fact that the bishop on
f8 is no longer on this diagonal
covering the
important dark squares it tactically
kind of works out for the fact that you
if you castle
you have to deal with the fact that 94
not only might
more or less threaten the move knights
d6 or something
but it's almost impossible to defend
against knight f
takes g5 and a subsequent checkmate on
h7 thanks to the opening of course of
this rook on h1
so i more or less expect the move e5 i
think the queen goes somewhere i
actually don't remember if it's forced
for it to go
to a particular location my memory is
pretty hazy on this one
and black will think about where to
castle depending on what white does
i think that's a fair opportunity though
for white i mean
getting the knight to e4 with that pawn
on e5 as you mentioned
the square d6 that's
that's some compensation i'm familiar
with the
bod vinnick uh pawn sacrifice and if
you're gonna go
a3 and i'm going to castle queen side
then i'm really happy about the move a3
because
normally in the baud minute you've got
in the move a3
a4 so okay i mean
double edged game for sure that's what
we want yeah and i also think i also
think b3 is on tap
still still you just don't have to worry
about
the uh i'm saying i still want to play
knight e4 and
start that demonstration but at some
point b3 will come especially
if you decide it's a long castle keep it
busy
the king on uh e1
well he'll probably have to castle at
some point
uh in his position but you'll be able to
enable with a4 in
some future event and you hope to be
able to shut down
anything black is doing i'm not
impressed now by the bishop on g7
and anything that black is doing on that
side of the board so
white will have to speed things up i
don't want to necessarily put a knight
on d6 because
i i know yasser yeah
before i could leave the knight let go
of the knight
off the d6 square the rook is going to
sack on it
so that move i'd probably hold back
but otherwise i think that there's some
compensation
that he has to play for is it enough
that's what chess is all about yeah in a
position in which
my first instinct is not to count the
pawns okay
because you don't care how many pawns
each side has there's a king on g1
there's a king on v8
files are open uh uh uh uh
i care i care
long-term potential for black but of
course the king on b8 being so weak the
bishop on b7 still
being um not a very strong piece right
certainly
we think this is how he's going to want
to play yeah and giri
he might say i you know i got i got one
of the weaker players but this position
isn't sharp you better pay attention
because one little slip by black and
white could be crawling all over him
my only concern for for white
well i have maybe a couple of concerns
but the main one
is the knight on f3 because
i like to know where my knights are
going and the knight on c3
oh it knows exactly where it's going e4
d5 and e4 d6 sorry the knight on
f3 someday you're gonna have to get some
work
like where what exactly is the right
plan
especially black castle's queen side
that knight's gonna need a few moves to
really do anything is this
gonna sit there it's blocking up the
action gumming up the works with the
bishop
sitting on e2 as well so the flow of the
position
feels off if you're if you're talking
about white
getting more and more energy even if you
land a night on d6 actually
even sitting there which we know is not
going to last long on that square
still the rest of the pieces are
wondering what is our avenue
to black's position how do we get over
to that side so that's
my main concern and the move e5 as
strong as it looks getting the square d6
it does concede the d5 square to a black
knight that you just controlled with the
move a3
he just slowed things down so now the
knight can say oh wait a minute i can
reside on d5 myself so
this game this is the one we're going to
really be paying attention to and why
we're happy in fact
of these kind of imbalance rating right
differences
because the top players well unlike the
game with aronian and the pulesku
they're going to try to beat the lower
rated players and this one is going to
keep our attention for sure
absolutely and you're right maurice i
mean when i do
if i'm in the on the black side and i
see the move e5
i do covet the d5 square and thinking to
myself
the knight on a6 needs a path
to a good square and knights i think we
are about to see the
end of a game as i expect a repetition
maybe we can get it on camera between
lupulescu
and aronia and i think they're headed in
that direction i don't imagine
either side is actually going to ever
try in this position we can maybe
get them and there it is queen d5 queen
d1
uh about to see a handshake in this game
i don't know if handshakes are allowed
a toe tap queen d5 yet looks like a
repetition i think they've called the
arbiter because remember they can't
offer draws but a repetition i think is
already on the board
that he's going to play queen d1 and
it's a repetition that's a threefold
and shake shake shake it over your hand
and that's after sanitizing after 75
years he didn't even make it to move 30
by the way
no a very dead drawn position
lupulescu well he played a very safe
opening
and that was kind of the end of the game
ironing didn't
actually pose any risk but let's go to
romania for more analysis
that was uh one of the draws uh of the
day very early one but i think we have
another one coming and uh actually i was
talking a little bit about
the game between grieschuk and mvl
because that was very interesting at the
beginning and i was questioning
nvr's decision to go for the groomfeld
well i think almira
has an answer for us uh tell us a little
bit about your interaction with mvl and
what do you know about
his choice to play the groomfeld hey
guys actually you know i had a chance to
interview mvl
just before this tournament for caspar
of chess
and uh well i asked him about the
candidates you know about the openings
how did it go especially this crazy game
against
fabi you know the night of so everyone
knows that nbl uses the nighter
and the greenfield those are his pet's
opening so and
actually that was also a chance for me
to ask him a question uh
about those openings because we were
filming a documentary about
nvl and uh as a surprise i told him that
his peers and gary kasparov they said uh
that in a very unusual manner you know
they usually don't talk about the other
players
so they said that mvl has a very narrow
repertoire
so it could be his strengths in his
positions very well but it also
could be like a weakness especially you
know during those tournaments where
players will target your preparation and
they will check the line so i asked him
like
maxim are you going to play those
openings once again
are you going to broaden me like your
repertoire
like and he was very confident he said
that he
liked this sharp position so much that
it suited him well he was like he's
he was like a fish you know in like in
french you're saying like
poison down low so he was feeling well
so and he said yes we're going to see
those i'm just going to analyze them
deeper and deeper
and here we are and uh of course he's
your friend and we're in no position to
give a 2800 player any advice
but do you think that's the right
strategy or uh
at least from your perspective well it's
like it's my personal opinion and you
know
and i am a classical example of a soviet
school you know i grew up in moldova so
uh well it is considered that especially
uh that nowadays the surprise value is
very important during those tournaments
sometimes you can use the idea only once
so you well you should have a few
openings under your belt you know what
you could use as a surprise weapon
so i think that maxim has those he just
considers that maybe that's not the
moment
yet but you know we know how the game
against fabio went you know and how
difficult it was i was just thinking
like what are you feeling during those
moments you know i know myself as a
player when you're facing such a novelty
you just go red you're s you just you
have to
to like to understand what is going on
to keep calm
and to find the best moves on the board
so uh
let's see if he has some surprises in
store for us absolutely let's see
and you're a pretty good friend of mvl
uh
would you tie his personality with his
choice
of continuing to play and going deeper
and just like
choosing to stay within his element
actually this is a very good pitch
because i was thinking about because
psychological dimension is very
important yes so i think
first of all maxim is a very
sincere
host with the
is also a very precise person
like he doesn't want to doubt so so he
very often would go
for a concrete variation because maybe
he doesn't feel well when there is some
things are not certain so i was thinking
maybe this could explain also
his opening choice well there you have
it guys a deep analysis
of mvl's brain and how it works and
how his choices of openings come to be
guys back to you
thank you christian and elmira um
live by the sword die by the sword uh
alejandro
but what a handling he has of that sort
he amir was mentioning the novelty that
fabi brought in the candidates
but the way that he handled it was just
amazing out of this world the way that
he was able to calculate his way out of
trouble it's true that eventually he
faltered
but at that point he had already kind of
refuted it over the board
extraordinary extraordinary really it is
uh
maurice uh jump right in yeah i just
i just feel as though sometimes the
reason why
we do things is not only
because we're good at them but because
we're afraid
of change right we're afraid of
uncertainty
and i'm a bit worried that with the way
mvl
stays in his lane all the time that
it's not creating opportunities for
growth
is what i will say and of course at the
top level it's easy
you know for me to say down here and
he's saying growth i got to play these
monsters these sharks
but it feels like maybe a missed
opportunity for him to
vary his opening somewhat get let him
let him
just venture into other waters that
would allow his eyes to see
different types of positions and grow in
new directions because he's seeing those
kind of setups so
i'm i i'd say that for me
i'd be pretty strong on saying to him if
i was a coach or an advisor which
i clearly will never be dude just let's
just
spread it spread the wealth a little bit
start to venture out be a little bit
more adventurous
but it seems as though his personality
does say i want to stick to what i know
this
works and i'm going to keep doing it
again and again whatever happens
yeah i have hiccups and accidents but
this is what i do
and some players just do that and that's
maybe what he's going to do for the rest
of his career
we will see maurice i think it's time
for a counter-attack
what do you say leandra we'll take a
very quick break
but before that we have to say that we
are proud to be partnering with kasparov
chess.com
it is a suite of tools of videos
of it's a playing zone an amazing
array of things that you can find at
casparofchaz.com and they have a series
of lectures
and we're going to leave you with one of
them by international master elizabeth
pates
on counterattack and we'll be right back
at the end of it
hello everybody i'm international master
sophiko guramushvili anushkiri
elizabeth kids love on iranian
to improve as a chess player you need to
get used to
recognizing patterns this was one of
those
lessons you get for life
[Music]
[Music]
this position is about the counter
attack what means in chess
counter attacking it means if your
opponent attacks you
then sometimes it's a very good recipe
to have a counter attack
therefore there are let's say two basic
rules which are good to know because
they will help you to find
the right move without searching for
the first step so that means if your
opponent attacks you on
a flank then you should look for the
counter attack
in the center or on the other flank
as one basic rule the other rule is like
if your opponent
attacks you in the center you look left
and right
for a counter attack on the flank with
those two basic rules actually it would
be much
easier to consider the right approach
from the start here in this position
black played the move
g5 this move g5 is a kind of
attack on the king side flank so
according to my rule i should
look for a counter-attack either in the
center
or on the other side of the board on the
flank
which one i should consider first well
this is quite
let's say in a way logical to explain
in the center usually the impact is
always
the biggest sometimes i like to compare
chess
to a game of bowling if you hit the
bullet and the bullet hits
in the center the destruction is huge if
the bullet hits on the rim
then the destruction is hardly possible
or hardly seen
that's why here looking at the position
for my
attacking counter attacking moves i have
two candidates
i have the move c4 and i have the move
a4
of course for most of you they would not
even consider a move like c4 because it
looks a little bit
dubious as black has two options to
capture
on c4 nonetheless c4 is closer to the
center than
a4 which means if c4 is working
usually the impact is much stronger than
a4
let's consider in case of the move a4 to
start with that
then black likely will not care so much
about this wing and will continue
playing g4
and attacking the knight the knight
should move somewhere let's say to e1
and here this position is absolutely not
clear because both sides have a lot of
chances
here probably black should just treat
the threat of atx b5
well let's say with rook b8 this should
be good enough
maybe even with another move like b4 so
we can already see that
a4 attacking on the other wing which is
less close to the center or more far
away
is not such a brilliant idea however
obviously possible
so let's watch out for the move c4 c4 is
attacking the center in a way
and now here black has um well a lot of
moves to come up with
let's first check the move g4 because
g5 was played so principally it's
logical
to continue the attack on the flank
playing g4
here white has a very good counter
attack or counter response
he would not care so much of the knight
on f3
he would simply capture on d5 because
the idea is
now that the knight on e4 is attacked so
if black
takes on f3 then we could simply capture
on e4
so we get our piece back and even if you
capture on g2
we wouldn't care we play a move let's
say like rook e1
i mean we wouldn't take with a king
because that pawn actually the enemy
pawn
is guarding the king in a brilliant way
from any
unnecessary checks to allow on g8 so
after rook e1 actually
once again white has a double attack on
e6
and c6 pieces and is simply winning the
game
as by material means it is already like
more or less equal
and we will win additionally a piece
either on e6
or on c6 so we can for this reason
rule out the move g takes f3 what other
moves do we have in this position
obviously we have to move bishop takes
d5
and now if the bishop takes c5 of course
we can consider to move away
our knight but maybe it's once again
much more interesting to hit in the
center
so a move like rook d1 here makes a lot
of sense as
rook takes g5 or bishop takes t5 are
very bad threats
so black would obviously take on f3
because it is a piece and
also it attacks the queen on e2 and we
will simply capture back on f3
and the threat of taking on d5 is
still remaining here are not the many
moves which
black can consider a passive defense
like knight e7
can result at least in capturing on d5
knight takes d5
and now queen takes e4 and once again we
get our piece back we attack the knight
on d5 and we have an absolutely winning
position
regarding also the aspect that the king
is still in the center
so that's why knight e7 does not make
any sense and we have to look for
something else
and now in this position actually
instead of the move
knight e7 we will play a move
like um knight takes e5 and after knight
takes e5 the easiest
solution is to simply play queen e2
and now once again um the bishop on d5
is under attack and after green e2 in
case of
c6 then we have simply the move knight
c3
and here we have a lot of pressure when
we speak about the center and we will
get back a piece and have
a winning position for this reason
actually in the game
g4 was not played it was played
something else
he took on c4 which is obviously also a
candidate move
now i have to resume back to the
position which is honestly not the
easiest thing in the world so
here after g5 c4
was played and we considered now all the
moves connected to the move
g4 but instead of g4 in the game b
takes c4 was happening d take c4 is
actually to be
ruled out immediately because the knight
on e4
is under attack so we can even like
consider moves like
rook d1 followed up by knight c3 ideas
or even um well queen takes e4 to me
looks like the easiest solution so
that's why in the game after c4b
takes c4 was played and what is the idea
of the sacrifice on c4
it is connected to the diagonal
a4 e8 so after b takes c4 in the game
bishop a4 was played with an attack on
the knight on c6
now the move queen d7 doesn't make
any sense as after knight d4 we increase
the attack on
c6 and if you capture on d4 we can
capture your queen with a check and win
substantial material
that's why after bishop a4 bishop d7
happened in the game
and now it's not so easy to continue and
obviously when you play c4
you should see all this kind of
continuation but
looking a little bit at this position we
should always try to hit in the center
as a kind of general rule
so we could get into the idea of pushing
the pawn to e6
what do we reach with e6 first of all
the bishop on d7
is not able to capture on e6 as it would
lose the control
of the knight on c6 so f takes e6 is
forced
but now with basically distracting the
pawn from f7
the whole diagonal e8 h5 is open up
so what we are aiming for a move like
knight e5
maybe then in connection with queen h5
what is disturbing
the knight on c6 that's why here white
captures on c6
forcing the recapture on c6 and pushes
knight e5
and now we have a double attack one
attack is we
would try to capture the bishop on c6
the other threat is queen h5
check and it's very hard to defend both
attacks
of course you can push h5 in order to
prevent queen takes h5 but then we would
capture just
the bishop on c6 and would be a piece up
even so black maybe has a little bit of
compensation
but still nobody would like to voluntary
give a piece
that's why in the game queen d6 was
played
um protecting the bishop on c6 and
having an escaping square to d8
and now black white gave a check on h5
king d8 is not quite possible because of
knight
f7 ideas so king e7 was played in the
game
and after bishop takes g5 check black is
forced to capture back on g5
queen takes g5 now king e8 is the only
move
and once again we will give a check on
h5
forcing the king to e7 d8 once again
because of knight f7 never works
and after king e7 we just win some
material after queen f7
check king d8 and queen f6 and then
capturing the rook on h8 i mean i agree
that this whole example is quite
sophisticated and very complicated
but the main message i would like to
deliver in this example is
when you get attacked on the wing always
automatically try to
consider a counterattack either in the
center or
on the other wing because this way you
would already consider the right
approach
from the start
[Music]
certainly a fascinating g5 in that open
spanish by lizzie i really love
that counter attacking lecture
well we have another result as we were
on break not surprisingly
uh taymor rajawa perhaps surprised
himself
by the regos and choice of fabiano caron
has opted to repeat moves early in the
position and that game
has ended in an extremely unexciting
draw fresh off his four draws against
neptu which was
very criticized for online well rajah
was just not able to find an idea under
ghost and chooses to
force the early repetition something
we've seen in this position many many
times
indeed we have and that is of course
this repetition
back and forth between these two bishops
it's a dance that has been seen
before as you've been mentioning uh
alejandro and it's
sort of like you just kind of threw away
a game with the white pieces
and from i don't know from uh fabby's
point of view
i mean it's an easy day at the office
you stay out of the office you don't
have to think at all
no not have to show a novelty to
equalize either you just save all your
preparation
we had talked about this about timor
earlier he's the type of guy that goes
maybe plus one maybe makes nine draws in
an event
and just ultra ultra ultra solid uh
well just really nothing to talk about
in this game exactly and maurice uh
during our break
i see that you've got the most exciting
position
on the board not surprisingly and what
has drawn
your eye well the guy castle queen side
as we had told the king white king's
still in the middle of the board
and black up a pawn the thing about this
position is
white needs brakes he needs something
to crack the position open the a4 brake
is that going to get it done here b3
looks like the most natural one
in the position but it has its
challenges as well certainly the a3 pawn
could potentially hang and in the
meantime i still
this knight is really really bothering
me it's knight on f3 i hate when knights
don't have real squares and this knight
would love to be
over here on d6 could i just get a
little love
and be able to do a long l and just drop
it on d6
now that would be a good shift of that
piece but where else how else do you get
it going anywhere
and by the way if g4 ever happens and
the knight gets on h4
it'll be stranded over on this square
but you don't know where to put i just i
just don't know where to put it it's
very much annoying me that the only star
in the position for white is this knight
on e4 but nobody else how does white
really prove anything here i think gary
is quite content to play a position like
this with the black pieces
and his opponent is going to have to
come up with something
pretty soon or else slowly but surely
black's going to start
getting his play thank you for that
maurice uh
strange rounds thus far uh alejandro
because it does appear to me
that that one game is going to be the
game of the round
because i'm looking at the game of mbl i
just saw between sasha and mvl i just
saw the move
e6 e5 liquidating the one weakness
that mvl had in the position and with
that move and trade
on e5 these players are in the bishops
of opposite color ending
that game's heading straight to a
draw wesley so um
very i never thought that i
that an exchange queen's gambit accepted
is actually
the second most interesting game of the
round it's just been that kind of a
round
as the player started start this
grand chess tour we just saw this move
roxy one and there you see
these players are just trading
everything off the board
g takes king takes and even if you took
one of the bishops off the board the
players would
be able to agree to a draw yep actually
with the bishop still on the board you
can mate exactly that's why you say you
give up your bishop you need to drop the
bishop so
uh that will be our third draw again i'm
just looking at the game between shaq
and wesley very even game
leaving us with the game between daniel
and anish i like what you were saying
there maurice about the
the the fact that white does have one
great
knight on on e4 but the knight on f3 it
would bother me as well
from my perspective as black if i could
get in the moves
oops excuse me i my cursor went a little
too far
if i could get in the move king c a to
b8 and c5 i'm
really starting to enjoy black's extra
pawn
and the bishop on b7 is opening up
does the computer find a concrete way
for white
to prove anything for the pawn no proof
no proof from what i'm seeing uh just
looking at these lines over here
it does suggest the move b3 if you may
play it on your board b3
as we said and after captures on b3
not captures on eight no not actually a3
giving chances to play queen to b2
whoa queen
to b2 not queen takes b3 where it is not
impressed
by recapturing a pawn which which
then by the way doesn't refute this
queen being on b3 just plays g4
and plays on the other side so i'm a bit
perplexed as to why
you would just leave this pawn sitting
on the
ah it's because you hate your nightmares
so that after after g4
you're defending the knight apparently
your
your queen is defending the pawn you you
don't have to go
uh somewhere bad you can take on b3 and
go to see
with the knight look at that that's deep
that is really
really deep you know you have this
impression that you're
uh training a student right right and
you're your student goes b3 you take it
and your student goes queen b2 right now
you're looking at the guy and you're
saying to yourself
why did you come to me for lessons first
of all you've got to learn
you know like what pawns are worth and
so on uh
queen bee2 i have an amazing move it's a
move that i understand because the
engine
suggested it and then i can explain it
but i would never have come up with this
move myself
right i just take on b3 and think later
yes but queen b2
as we understand that knight on f3 which
was
shall we say triggering maurice like i i
need that knight to do something
you were trying to make the illegal move
knight f3 to d6 but
knight f3 to d2 to b3 to c5
i like that that looks good i like that
that's the yeah that's
very extraordinary in fact and so
counter-intuitive because we would
automatically as you said take back
on b3 but we've got to worry about the
d4 square
if your knight wants to get to greener
pastures
you can't even play knight d2 right now
because you're simply
hanging d4 so how do you do it
effectively
to not hang the square the point of b3
and queen b2
is absolute genius uh the computer can't
appreciate our compliments
but he doesn't even know it's being
complicated absolutely
amazing i think for a lot of people in
our audience
they would say come on guys you guys are
grandmasters
explain it to us why shouldn't we play
knight d6
why shouldn't white be
happy to win in exchange how would you
go about
explaining why the move knight d6 plays
right into black's hands
uh well the first thing is that i'm not
entirely sure you take on d6 here
but okay in in the case that you do take
on d6 it basically removes
white's threatening piece his best piece
best piece that knight on e4 it has this
latent power
it looms on c5 it looms on d6 you don't
really know where the knight's gonna go
and here you've eliminated this knight
it cost you a rook yes but you also got
a powerful pawn for it
your bishop on g7 now feels very free in
the position
basically you have eliminated danger
and you've given yourself activity all
at the cost of an exchange for a pawn
uh excuse me two pockets you're already
down upon
so that means you already ain't even
down mathematically any material right
you're actually doing just fine
bishop and two pawns for a rook you got
a bishop and two pawns
so no number game there and all the
pluses you mentioned alejandro that
black suddenly has
where shobi white's best piece white's
most advanced piece at the moment
is that dark knight on f3 again which by
the way
is like where are you going because e5
is also covered
in this position so to be fair this
does improve the knight on f3 which
might be the only argument on why i
would
maybe consider to play king b8 because i
don't think the knight on d6 does
anything immediately
no it doesn't and i think if i can do if
i'm really
greedy about this i actually want to
play g4 first
yes fourth chapter something dumb
and then take on d6 when it can't go to
e5
and no longer guards d4 right
right right and it longer guards d4 it's
an important point the bishop will be
immediately taking that pawn
so if i can just play devil's advocate
for a moment and
give you a position like this right
where now
you say okay now i'm going to take this
guy and i'm going to feel really good
about black's position because this
knight on f3
is on this dumb square horrible you
can't go to e5
you do have the two bishops you're not a
down any kind of material
and it's very easy game for black black
knows that he wants to bring his knight
to
d5 he black knows he wants to play c5 in
this position by the way
you better watch your d4 pawn because
he's going to land on d8
i don't even think you can defend it
there's no move to defend it and that
pawn is
cool it's it's all going it's one-way
traffic
fair enough i mean okay but um for me
it was really yeah i wasn't playing king
b8 i was playing
it takes immediately but i'm beginning
to appreciate that
well the knight on d6 looks good but
uh if you don't have an immediate
follow-up like a4 or
a3 then it just it's not going to win
the game on its own
no i kind of expect the move b3 i don't
expect
cb queen b2 that is a little
fantasy for me uh it would be cool to
see it like what a genius that guy is
right but to me b3 makes sense you take
you kind of force
c takes p3 i don't really think there's
another move in the position well
we haven't really looked at it but queen
takes a three takes
the reason i was attracted to queen
takes a3 is because we played a3 with a
specific purpose
of keeping this knight out of the game
and suddenly it was like uh
you know the mummy you know returns the
knight uh
does get to the square b4 and queen b1
here between b1
okay i think you really don't consider
this if white's already cancelled
because it's starting to look suspicious
exactly and i don't think you're going
to really do anything
yeah it's really based on the idea that
you haven't yet
castled and whether or not i can play
you know a crazed move like c5
you got what well like well i was
thinking that
i've got some queen c3 check ideas maybe
in case of knight take c5 but the king's
gonna hide on f1 no it's gonna be pretty
secure on that
that's the problem yeah black white just
seems like suddenly white has some kind
of chance
imagine this position if i played some
move like g4
as a preface again i
i've had well i've looked at enough
uh i want to say bob vinnick pawn
sacrifice games to know that uh
there is a danger to both players kings
and uh these double-edged positions okay
but
uh but but here yeah here in that
position
at least white has got some some play
oh i don't know question i don't see
what white's doing otherwise he's like
you know if you're black you say i'm
gonna shut you down right you know you
don't know which one but
i agree unless if you suspect that queen
b2 is coming if we can go back
if you suspect that if i take on
b3 this guy might play the move queen b2
with the idea of knight d2 knight b3
then you might start thinking about the
queen a3 waters
because that's such a profound idea
maybe
maybe for that reason do we switch the
order around and after b3 do we play g4
first you do hang g4
as a tempo it does depend where the
knight goes because i take on b3 with
the tempo so if you go to d2
my point is that the queen's not on b2
yet i could take on d4 i don't know if
it's good or bad for me but
well let's see it because that's gonna
be action jackson
take on c4 here right and
whoa well this got sharp fast we will
continue on this line but knight d6
check was played instead of the move b3
oh boy wow uh-oh wow
i don't think it's that bad but as the
engine bar still
remains level from what i can see it 8d6
it might the engine might say whatever
it likes but this feels like
i i mean if i was playing blitz i would
have pre-moved
exactly exactly but knight d6
check um i'm surprised i i really liked
uh
where we were going with the b2 b3
variations
and d6 feels so simplistic right just
let's just put a good night
put a knight on a good square
essentially and it's going to sit there
but it's
it's just a it's just not a knight that
bothers black that's the pro
when the knight lands on an advanced
square you're the other
the other the opponent should be
thinking that thing's got to go
that's got to go but not so much here
but we will jump
to romania as our colleague christian
carrillo
has a special guest for us
thank you maurice yes i'm here with
alexander grishou who just
finished his game against nvla sasha
first of all welcome
to romania welcome to bucharest and
welcome to the show hi
and thank you uh it's a pleasure first
of all to interview you i know you are
such a legend but first take us through
the game no but there is nothing to
discuss is just
a four stroke were you surprised by
mvl's opening choice or absolutely not
no of course i was surprised he
plays grunfeld very rarely
what do you think about this choice of
his he's been playing grunfeld pretty
much
his whole life he tried it a little bit
in rapid games during some of
uh the other tours also during
candidates he played grunfeld what do
you think about this strategy
yeah i mean it's a bit funny that there
are two
players at the very top with completely
similar
repertoires uh him maxim and
jan both plays
exclusively gruenfeld and neither for
their whole
lives yeah it's a bit strange you know
coincidence would you say uh
is somewhat similar as to your
um tendency to go into time travel let's
say
it's within your element and the
groomfeld is within his element would
you
be able to make that comparison not
really i mean this
this is an opinion but also both of them
try to play fast you know both are very
good tacticians
so yeah it's i mean it's a bit funny
that there are two
extremely similar players at the very
top because
you if you take others then there are
differences here between
each of them yeah like let's say you
take magnus and karwana okay they're
different in some ways you take karwan
and wesley they're different you take
nakamura and wesley they're different
but those two are the most
similar players at the top did you have
any surprises prepared for uh him in
this game or no no it's just a draw yeah
i just did the research i in my last
10 maybe first round games i
think maybe made four draws and lost six
so i thought draw is better than losing
so this was planned all along well thank
you very much sasha
and we're looking forward to see you
next thank you
thank you christian thank you sasha's
always this dry
humor i was thinking like a draw is
better than a loss
after six losses you can ten games if
you look at the scoring system
a draw is a half a point better than a
loss
that's why they keep telling me uh
interesting comparison he was making
there between nepo who is
actually the challenger to the world
champion yes
uh who's playing najdorf his whole life
he's playing groomfeld his whole life
and he's the challenger world champion i
will have to say nepo has tried
some other openings once in a while
famously in the candidates including
that french defense in the first half
certainly nearly cost of the challenger
the challenger got a lost position i
guess alex tinker got smashed by mvl
yes but he did try it he's trying to
broaden his repertoire
i think that's a big point the it's the
attempt it may not
result uh positively the first few times
you do it
and i'm not sure i would do it in the
candidates by the way the first time
but it's the attempt the attempt shows
bravery it shows a willingness to
experiment even in difficult
circumstances important circumstances
i should say and that's that's
why nepal is the challenger because in
addition to being a freaking genius and
a fantastic player
he is willing to put himself on
the line and that's what growth
opportunities for growth
lie so no question about that but listen
to that interview
with the christian it's simply amazing
so alex uh sasha tell us some things
about the game go through the game
no need to it's just a draw
i can't argue with that either that's
what makes sasha such a great interview
he looks incredible what you're gonna
get with the guy
and i do remember mvl going out of his
element to play
not the night or but the karo khan once
against fabio and walked into
some of the greatest preparation we
we've ever been an
amazing g4 move that raviano had
prepared against
somebody else and mbl walked
right into it and he was like no no
night off for me for the rest of my life
and speaking of the frenchman he is with
our colleague christian carrillo
thank you alejandro yes i'm here with
mvl who just finished his game against
grishouk first of all welcome to
bucharest is this your first time in
romania it's my first time in romania
and yeah i like it very much here
what are your first impression after
going to the opening ceremony but also
the playing hole is everything uh going
okay for you i think everything's fine
the opening ceremony i thought was
brilliant
so like maybe it took a little bit too
long to my taste but
that's every chess player like uh we
want to come back to the hotel room to
to prepare for the games but otherwise i
think we had a great time
i mean it was very organized and we had
lots of good times with
the local players and the children
during the semester absolutely and uh
the first game was
more or less uneventful let's say were
you surprised by uh
alexander's strategy were you like
concerned that he might come with any
new ideas
yeah i was surprised uh and actually on
the options that
uh that we prepared something i didn't
go
this uh knight c5 where we have
this uh perpetual
and with d7 so at this point you were
just worried that you might have made
some sort of no i mean i knew this is
equal but i thought maybe
maybe sasha wants bishop g5 or bishop h6
and i knew that this is also very safe
for me
um but yeah i didn't expect sasha to
to make a quick draw but
you know i i take it of course i prefer
to have
fighting games and of course it's a pity
that for the first day
we didn't uh we were already out of
three draws but
well let's hope that in the next days we
will fight more and i'll definitely try
to play my part in that
and we know we're absolutely in no
condition to uh
question your opening choice but you've
been playing the groomfeld all your life
uh you've played it during the canvas as
well what is your thinking process
continuing to go with the greenfield
further in your career it seems like
yeah well in general it gives good
positions and
well i mean i don't mind getting an easy
draw with black
uh like today of course um
so our days were you know it's much more
difficult and also much more fighting
depends
and yeah i mean i've tried other
openings as well and
uh um can't say that i won't come back
to these
other openings or even completely
brand new openings at least for me but
gunfire has suited me well i know a lot
of things there so
i don't see any reason not to play it on
a regular basis
you definitely do know a lot uh you
showed us two ways in which you could
have equalized this position
uh what are your ambitions for this
tournament i want to play well
i want to come back you know into
the top 10 because i i mean for the
first time in five years i'm not in
there because of uh
my tournament in vacancy and um
yeah i'm definitely hoping um you know
play well with some games and you know
that's generally the strategy of when
you want to do in a tournament so
i can also hope for that if all goes
well
well there you have it guys a very
ambitious and
ready to fight mvl watch out back to you
guys
thank you christian a quick uh question
for maxine
he's wearing the face mask uh sasha did
not
is it optional in romania for the
players to have a mask or not
oh i'm sorry okay can't hear me i was
just curious
because i see that some players are not
wearing well we'll get you that
information no problem thank you
but what a surprise to me hearing mvl is
not part of the top 10 that's almost
incredible when you think no no it
really is i was like
no he's been a reporter part of the top
10.
wow nobody cares about those numbers
ratings and viel is part of the top ten
he'll
he'll fix that shortly no question about
it come on after the move knight d6
check anish uh maurice has
just uh kind of tanked a little bit
because king b8 is decent and
rook d6 is decent that's right he's
definitely not considering queen d6
so what is he looking at king b8 we we
think
is the only alternative to rook takes on
d6 and he's studying carefully because
like us aneesh in a blitz game will
probably have just
clocked that night on d6 as soon as it
showed up
on the board or on a computer screen
this this is a typical exchange sack
used to be back in the day
sacking the exchange for a single pawn
was considered not enough compensation
just simply not enough a rook was
super impressive but as time passed and
guys like botvanic and petrosian and the
whole soviet school
just seemed to sack exchange after
exchange after exchange
like it was going out of style actually
it was suddenly in style
everybody started under understanding
the differences
in how many ways you can sacrifice not
just a typical rook takes c3
in a sicilian for example but in so many
other positions
this was possible especially when and
this is the
significant reason especially when the
opponent's rooks
don't have open files if they don't have
open files to just run
rampant over your position then you're
the one with the pieces
that will begin to show their teeth for
example as you pointed out he has his
bishop
lining up along the long diagonal after
c5
a knight co lane on d5 and of course
this bishop will breathe fire
down this diagonal but he has to be
careful uh
in this line in these kinds of lines
that white doesn't open up the game some
way and give the white rooks
a chance to breathe that's the dynamic
should he play
before taking before playing king b8 or
right now that's what anish is
considering
very deeply uh he's studying multiple
lines to be sure
to confirm which one he'll play will he
play king v8 now or rook d6 now
anish a tremendous player indeed
he has been growing over the last year i
will say it seems like he's just
getting more variety in his play would
you say guys he seems more impressive
and he also won one of
the champions tour events so he's he's
starting to show some teeth
every he used to have and he's done it
rook takes d6
he said i don't want to think about it
anymore i'm just killing this guy
right now enough of the nuances the move
has been made
if it if it hadn't been made with king
b8 after king b8 first it would have
been made anyway
we know that was going to happen but he
decided to do it right now was it the
right moment
we don't know but the enterprising
aneesh has been coming out
of the woodworks more and more where
this moniker he had of
droish anish is going by the wayside as
he's winning
much more games of late and he's always
always been one of the most fighting
players over the board
his results tons of draws but if you
analyze his games he was always trying
to put his foot forward
it wasn't the type of player that's
super solid yeah
trying that moscow candidates tournament
was a real
outlier right i mean he draws all of his
games and he gets
you know chris eyes for it but look at
those games three of the games he was
probably winning or should have actually
won he was fighting in every single game
and
it was a very undeserved criticism but
you're absolutely right he
works tirelessly he's trying to improve
and i think the second half of the
candidates
showed just what a resurgent uh force in
the gay
in in chess but that said that said yes
sir
yeah it's you know there there's a
difference between
you make a draw because you're solid or
you make a draw
because you don't have the killer
instinct so i think
let's just not say it's a completely
unfair criticism if you're getting those
one positions
get the job done right if you're going
to be a world champion
and he has every right to aspire to
become the champion of the world
get the job done you've got to kill
people you've got to knock them out you
can't just
get good positions yeah you're playing
fighting chess congratulations
and not win the game so aneesh
the one of the knocks was anish would
always find a way to draw
even winning positions right that's true
that's a knock
that's that's legit you've got to add a
little spice
add a little something in how you
convert in order to
actually win those fighting positions
you're getting
and so yes you're right he's not just
playing solid draw he was not only
playing those
solid draws i just want to make a draw
he just wasn't finishing the job
lately we're watching him get the job
done
and his opponent there he seems like
he's not so scared right now
after that exchange sack he just castled
and i think he thinks the position is
fine for him
right now that it's just a dynamic
imbalance what a great imbalance it is
though
yeah yeah the bishop and two pawns uh
middle game kings on opposite flanks who
do you like
it's hard to say uh personally i'm not a
big fan of rooks i like my bishops i
would probably take black if i was given
a choice in this position out of
instinct
the more i see it the more i see that
black does have some problems in
developing
all of his pieces because i really want
to get the c5 break in
but at the same time it's so weakening
and for my own king
and i don't really want to open the rook
on d1 i don't really want to get rid of
my weakness on
my opponent's weakness on d4 exactly so
i'm not sure uh i'm also kind of
wondering
if white is just going to pre-move the
move knight e5 like no matter what i do
if i play something
like king b8 or knight c7 do i just gift
this pawn and say i'm going to get rid
of the pair of bishops this knight has
been a
pain for white for the entirety of the
game let me just get rid of it
uh yes it costs a pawn sweep
[Laughter]
play rookie one play rookie one and then
pre-move it
uh
like like this rookie one in this moment
sorry
yeah maybe do it like this that way when
you play knight e5 then
there's no double capture on e5 that
you've got to worry about i'm just
saying
like right because you've got a heart
attack yeah yeah because you got uh
bishop takes c4 at the end
of a double capture on the e5 square and
maybe
okay um
i can imagine that this is uh
i personally am with you i like the
bishops i like the pawns i like the fact
that
uh the majority on the queen side
uh can sometimes just win the game on
its own
exactly exactly so this is a game we're
definitely going to keep an eye on
the other remaining game for us is a
game of wesley so
and um what can you tell us about this
game
it feels super balanced but uh
is there something in this for white
well we have to see if knight c4 can put
any kind of pressure i'm not really sure
i have a real
i have a real thread with a3 and b4
maybe a3 b4 or
a3 knight a5 maybe something like this
might be uncomfortable all right knight
c4 is the only move i can use exactly
i mean you don't want to play knight c2
i mean what's the night go
why is a good night going around yeah
knights before knight c4
and again uh the question is um
are you really doing something so let's
imagine that
i just throw out a bishop to d5 to
sidestep
maybe the effects of a3 and knight a5
again i don't have another idea
maybe it's not the best move but as a
human i don't have another idea about a3
right i kick out this bishop um
i guess i go b4 i'm not really sure what
guys with this
stop you know wesley is not going to
lose his game
you're trying to push in this position
we got to do something
you know we've already got three draws
under our belts here
we're trying to look for some kind is
that some serious pretending for the
fans right now
making moves like this this position is
you know what this position is let's see
if wesley screws up somehow
let's make a few moves and then we'll
make the draw because
this one is equal equal equal if
anything
smg meaning a little bit like white
might pretend
but come on this is gm draw written all
over it
and we'll see you can any any move you
want to try folks at home in this
position with white as long as you don't
hang a piece
is as good as anything alejandro and
yasser suggests right now
because there's just nothing much
happening in this position
for either side and you just heard it
okay uh it looks very very balanced to
our eyes and therefore that is why we've
been returning
to uh this one whoa
i was getting in 97 or some other half a
tempo but he said g4
wow and you've got to play knight e5
yeah that's the only that's clear
we we've already mentioned that moves
like knight h4
or knight h2 are going to be met by h5
and the knight will be
offsides one day bishop takes d4
followed by c6
e5 is going to cost you the game hence
95 was forced
immediately we gave up our beautiful
bishop by the way
and i think
hey what just happened i am so relieved
by
audacious choice you couldn't breathe as
wide a second ago you were begging for
open files
you know it was like miracle of miracles
the guy forces the files open your rook
can go to e1 and get a tempo
bishop drops back to f3 okay i don't say
we're winning
but at least you told us what to do
thank you
why did he make this choice aneesh there
was no subtlety in his play
pure barbarism you're just like i'm just
going to play straight
maybe he thinks that knight's going to
land on d3 maybe he might just
gonna check me with h4 uh that's
that's maybe i mean why not right i mean
the bishop let's say he retreats
he could throw in the move rook if you
want that's also we need to consider
right rookie one has got to be the move
right like chasing the queen away
chase the queen and wait for it all
right uh the unfortunate thing for black
is that i don't actually have a choice
about where the queen has to go it has
to go it could go to g7 but it looks
kind of silly i assume it has to go to
f6
the reason it can't go to c7 which would
normally be a natural move is that i
think queen c3 just picks up the pawn on
h5 on h5 because i don't think you can
keep the rook on the h file
you probably will get mated on the
eighth rank if you do gotcha
so enough uh queen f6
i don't think queen g7 makes any sense
well here though the problem is i go
bishop
f3 a4 and h3
uh maybe my bishop is being hit right
yeah my bishop has to go
i don't like rookie one how is the
bishop being hit i'm sorry
okay sorry uh we were thinking that if i
go rook he won
we're thinking maurice that after queen
f6 bishop f3
h4 yeah and the problem with g4
is h3 and that's how the bishop
is being undermined so like do you have
a threat
yeah i'm just i don't know i'm actually
wondering
is a threat that's what i'm saying like
maybe five
three the thing that i don't like long
term about black's position from a
general perspective of course h3 looks
very threatening and stuff but if it
doesn't actually accomplish
anything the more you open up this
position remember that black doesn't
have a bishop he has a knight now
exactly the rooks are happy yeah the
rooks are very happy to open this
position you open the h file i'll be
like well thank you i have two rooks
i'll win that file
and excuse me but queen d2 is a threat
isn't it like
queen d2 looks like a monster threat uh
that will appear in the position at some
point if you put my bishop on f3 you're
qui
if i play rookie when your queen goes to
f6 and i play bishop f3 i'm just like
you you play your move yeah i mean
you're h4 moving hard right right unless
i play queen d2
like ar are you doing something
yeah i mean that i'm i'm coming on d6 or
d7
i don't know what you're trying to do
with your your h4 demonstration maybe
c5 is just about enough well you better
come up with
with something timely uh right now queen
d6 is met wait yeah you have to go
knight
knight d3 because that's hanging you do
have knight d3 and i don't have
bishop takes c6 that's the move i'd like
to play if i hit
but if i hit on d though and then take
on cc i'm certainly not
losing there's no way i mean
no no you have to find some way to
survive this position this is this is
this might just be lost for black
whoa whoa whoa that's that's rook d8 is
still
double-edged right no no rook d8
well the engine didn't like it mate
oh that's gross queen f8 and you've been
observed
well but this is what i'm talking about
i think this is what all of us are
talking about isn't it
getting old you open up the files
what did you do but that's the other
question is
in in this position why would you ever
i mean if you wanted to play g4 and kill
the bishop like
the move g4 is marvelous is it
if you have the time to also play h5
then the bishop on e2 is not going
anywhere it's
really dominated uh but queen takes e5
bishop takes g4 just
lets white out completely a very strange
decision
a bad move just a bad move i was
thinking knights e7
we were looking at something like 1977
anyway right right and the knight would
have landed on d5 and who knows what
would have
been the case but as anish played it oh
by the way guess what we've just seen
the move queensland no no no no this is
your yourself we have we have the live
board on the left
for everybody that's what sorry that was
our analysis exactly so let's try to
understand this so
we're saying we're saying bishop three
is this rook
rook effie one first because it does
force the queen to have sex according to
us
okay uh bishop f3 and
now you better watch queen now as a
reason d2 queen d6 looks very
threatening i mean b3 is also very
threatening e3 is also an option exactly
okay so what if we go knight c5 knight
c5
is a a saner move than h4 but then why
did i play h5
thank you exactly like didn't i just
force the bishop on g4 to a better
square yeah it's very strange right then
we
played in this move order exactly
this might be a good time to get a
lesson
from the gary kasparov counter-attacking
school of chess
because uh anish gary is playing some
very strange moves in
uh our how many pawns is it it's
two pawns just two pawns because so we
can't just win one back we have to win
more than one the thing is we were so
discussing this position when it was
three points
right and we still thought white has
some some play
right but the g pawn just kind of
disappeared out of my magic right
and made white a very very happy camper
indeed
yeah well and we have
uh more lessons from the website we're
partnering with kasparov chess.com
highly encourage you to visit it brand
new has a playing zone
has many many lectures has documentaries
including one
following maxine vacherola graph
absolutely
excellent content including the lecture
that we're gonna about
to show you on a famous game one of the
most famous games of chess
the opera game we'll leave you to it and
we will be
right back with our remaining two games
of the round
[Music]
the opera mate is named after
the opera game which probably is one of
the most famous
games ever played it involves
paul morphy american legend 19th century
superstar
and he was playing in a consultation
match between
the duke of brunswick and count isaward
at the opera
in fact now this rumor goes
that the duke of brunswick invited paul
morphy
for just a night at the opera you know
he said
hey i've got a box why don't you come
and enjoy yourselves we'll have a great
time
morphe who loved oprah said well
why not i'm gonna have a wonderful night
so murphy turned up and to his
horror the duke plus friend
said well hang on a second let's play
a consultation match and in order for
you to concentrate
paul why don't you sit with your back
towards the opera
now paul as we all know being a big
opera fan was
not impressed he thought well that is
not ideal
but he reluctantly agreed after all
listening to the opera was probably
bound to help his chess
so the game went e4
and the duke of brunswick and count
israel were paying back
played e5 knight f3 and as we
saw in earlier games d6 was all the rage
in 19th century chess
d4 and the count and the duke played
bishop g4 which is already an inaccuracy
d takes e4 and in order not to lose a
pawn
the duke played bishop takes f3
queen takes f3
and pawn takes pawn so you must remember
every turn paul morphy is trying to
end the game so that he can enjoy the
music
so this is why he played bishop c four
threatening scholars mate queen takes f7
uh naturally they didn't fall for that
knight at
six and queen came to b3
now black responded with queen e7
now it's a very funny moment in the game
because i think
everyone would probably have just taken
the pawn
and said okay fine we'll be a pawn up
but murphy did not want to allow queen
to b4 particularly when there was a
danger that the game might not end
so quickly so instead he chose
to eliminate that possibility
and instead played knight c3
the duke and the count played c6
and morphe played bishop g5
now it's a very curious position because
this just looks like a very normal
opening position
but black has developed a little bit
strangely with the queen being
on e7 hindering this bishop on f8
however when you look closely it's
actually
incredibly difficult for black to make a
move if he plays a natural developing
move like knight d7
well now the pawn on b7 will be on
freeze
so that isn't possible this bishop on f8
cannot get out because well that's
thanks to the queen on e7
so it was out of desperation that the
duke
and the count came with b5
trying to kick this bishop away the
chess is timing
and when you have the initiative you
really must play very
powerfully and this is a model
example of that it's not for morphe to
turn back
instead he is looking to open lines and
open diagonals so he can continue with
his attack
knight takes b5
pawn takes knight
bishop takes pawn check
and already you can see there is a big
problem
with the black king the king obviously
does not want to
go into the open with d8 so
the player black played knight eights to
d7
so what you do when you have a position
like this
you invite all your pieces for the
attack and
murphy know the root knows the rules and
so he castled
queen side bringing the rook into the
game
now rook takes d7 bishop takes d7 is a
really serious threat so all the duke
and the count could do was play
rook to d8 close their eyes and
hope for the best how to continue the
attack
from there again you must look at ways
of continuing the attack with powerful
measures
you cannot sit there and play developing
moves
such as a round move h3 no once you have
started you've got to finish
that's why they played rook takes d7
rook takes d7 and now rook
came to d8 and black played
queen e6 there really is no
move for black to play and here
it's a great moment in the opera game
and what i like about this game is that
the checkmate
comes in a different square than you
expect it to
white's pieces are very active on the
light squares and you kind of think well
perhaps
this checkmate will take place in the
light squares unfortunately
it doesn't it is the dark square bishop
that
steals the game so
murphy played bishop takes rook
knight takes bishop and we can see
the bishop is now pointing to d8
we have the rook on d8 but
there is a knight in its way what do we
want we want to play rook d8
what do we have to do we have to get rid
of the knight on d7
who can do that let's ask our pieces and
find out
i think the solution is pretty clear
it's the checks
the captures and the attacks queen to be
eight knight takes queen
and this is the opera mate in action
rook came to d8 it's an attack on the
uncasted king
and it's lethal so develop your pieces
hello everyone and welcome back to st
louis and uh the grand chess tour what
are you holding
on i am holding a poster that you can
buy
at cubitique our boutique at the world
chess hall of fame
you can find it uh i think we have the
website
below absolutely there you go shop at
qboutique stl.com
you can find all kinds of chess gadgets
chess posters
all kinds of really cool chess things if
you have any
friends or family that enjoys chess
gifts i highly highly recommend they
have all kinds of
creative t-shirts stuff creative chat
sets all kinds
highly recommended and well this is just
one of the many really pretty things
that we have over there
as you see the world chess hall of fame
and the
huge chess king the largest chess piece
in the world
in front i've seen so many people taking
their photos
as we get caught up on this first round
of play we have to
tell it's not been the best opening
round
so far we've already had three draws i'm
looking at the game between
shaq and wesley so and after
and here's the current standings after
three
draws alejandro well that is not a very
surprising set of standings after three
trials
no you've got six players start for
first that's how it works
and everybody with half a point not much
to say there
uh we also kind of expect wesley to end
up holding this position against
mamedyarov honestly i prefer white's
position but
it is a bit on the dry side absolutely
i would expect mamidarov to try at least
a little bit
to push wesley in this position i see
from black's point of view in these
types of positions
it's all about the c file um
as that open file usually the
the d and c files are the crucial files
but
in this particular setup with these
minor pieces on d5
and d7 it's obviously the c file
is what we're going to contest and if
white can do something it's got to do
something in the next few moves
but where the action is happening
maurice
please get it off the screen we'll look
at it some other time
if it gets interesting but the game that
could be
the absolute massive massive development
in the event is this one between
the romanian replacement
replacement player last minute play
replacement player bogue just came in at
the very end because
richard report could not play due to
illness
can you imagine how all of romania would
feel
having him knock off one of the best
players on the planet
that's huge news he being first by
himself
is what we're projecting if the shakriar
mahmoud versus wesley's soul game
stays true to form it's still a long
ways away but it could indeed happen
and bought this gentleman into front
page news
in bucharest h4 was played
guys and this is the position it looks
as if anisha is trying to drum up some
baby threats and on the h line this is
something he could simply ignore
a b3 thrust could be dangerous queen d2
is also good in this position both moves
are saying to black
i don't think you have anything like
what are you trying to do instead i'm
the one that you donated
gifted to open files to this position is
extremely dangerous for anish he's got
to watch out
he's really folks he forced this
position
on himself and now still maybe he's
confident that he can hold this
but i think that part of that confidence
is due to the fact that his opponent
is not as highly rated not a top 10
player
but 26 hundreds can punch two and
watch out because there's no reason for
white to fear this position
as far as i'm concerned is whether or
not he can make anything of it
and he's digging deep because this could
be his moment in the sun
absolutely queen d2 sure has my
attention oh
maurice i want you to show us those
computer lines i'm actually very curious
what the correct
path here is for white because when you
have two good choices
you're always left wondering which one
do i v3 or queen d2
give us some highlights of queen d2 if
you don't mind
uh maurice looking at the engine now
uh the plan as far as the engine is
concerned
is actually to play for b3 no matter
what including with the move
queen d2 so b3 is really the principle
to move
queen e2 could happen and after knight
c5 check this out queen d
oh okay queen d2
knight to c5 in this position the
computer actually
still plays b3 as a move and my board i
better be careful
that makes sense because if you take on
b3 queen d6 yes
so here of course and there's no knight
d3 knight
dropping to the wrong direction suddenly
you can play well here in this position
there's a queen d7 even
yes uh can be hit my computer's taking
time to load but i'm noticing
87 myself with a bishop c6 threat and uh
that position's falling apart
pretty quickly in fact so
that this line b3 back here
b3 could also be played immediately
get this going just get the action going
saying what is black doing the main line
by the engine is this this
takes and takes and there is no
mating construction on this side or
attack for black that
you can forget about that what you're
going to have to think about is the
position that's going to happen very
shortly a c6
is going to be weak your knight can't
easily get into the game this queen is
going to flex his muscle
pretty quickly to play devil's advocate
what do you play against queen g5 here
queen g5 the engine gets queen b2 king
queen c5
and queen c5 it actually is marching
which seems insane
uh to play this way oh uh allowing
well then wow
you didn't want to allow rook h1 but the
computer says no problem no
problem the rooks doesn't seem to be a
problem in this line
i don't know yeah i've been trying to
avoid looking at the engine's moves
and trying to be more logical where
we're back here
actually uh in the position
just three played just filling it out
what did he play b three b three
three so be on the board so there it is
the most principal move in the position
begging to be played
it is now on the board and that it just
makes a lot of sense this move b3
we liked queen d2 as well but
i don't think white has any fear
whatsoever everything aneesh did
was to help white's position to clarify
it make it a lot easier to play
there is nothing for white to worry
about there are no threats
anywhere i think i think my point would
be that
this kind of position if you're getting
h4 and
trying to open that rook and the guy can
just ignore it and play king f1 can you
then really your attack is nothing
that's a very bad sign
yesterday they had some very nice
opening ceremony
and we've got some highlights that we'd
like to bring on the show for
opening ceremony yesterday
welcome everybody to the opening
ceremony of the superbad chess classic
the first leg of the 2021 grand chester
held here
in buberus romania this is the opening
ceremony we have a lot of things planned
for you
so let's get the action started
[Music]
me and together with all the volunteers
from the
superbed foundation we really was so
happy that
uh gary kasparov
gave us this opportunity to have the
wonderful
chess tournament here oh it's it's a
very symbolic event
you couldn't describe it better because
it's the it's the beginning of a chess
season
because for 15 months you know chess was
hiding in in
in online but the fact is that despite
all these challenges
the event could be organized and not
simply organized but you know such a
beautiful
facility and in in the whole overall
environment
i'm really looking forward to playing
again getting on the board it's been a
while
it's uh it's sort of a new feeling not
playing online actually playing in
person chess
so really looking forward to it god
please let this
event happen no more delays and no more
cancellations and
here we are and tomorrow is going to be
the first round and
i'm very very excited it was a wonderful
day
here at the opening ceremony of the 2021
super bed
chess classic we had a lot of fantastic
activities
i hope you guys enjoyed the players are
ready the fans are ready
let's start the action
for that that was a beautiful ceremony
that looked like a lot of fun why where
was our invites i mean come on i know
we're in st
louis but still we would expect
something
and i have a special announcement for
everybody we have a great commentary
team but we'll be joined by the
legendary
gary kasparov in only 20 minutes so
watch out as he puts
his input on the very exciting
annihilatory game
and of course on all the developments of
the granchester which
he has pioneered absolutely and b2
b3 maurice is we just went on a little
break there
as you said that's the most principle
move for white to make to open up the
position get a
black's king what is the computer val
after b3 why it's better
but i don't think we're surprised by
that evaluation at all
uh be forget about the b3 move by itself
just look at white's pieces white's
pieces are great white had options
in this position so there was there's no
doubt about that b3
is is not whether or not white's better
it's
how much is white better and is white
really making the kind of progress
that's going to smash
black's position and that is not clear
that it goes that far
according to the engines but for me it's
just
the way anisha's handled his business in
this game that has been
shocking he just went so full on
aggressive
like he could just destroy his opponent
he played all the straightforward moves
and it's just backfired completely just
completely
and not in an unpredictable way if
you're going to open up the files with
the rooks you know when you're second
exchange guys
keep the rooks calm we said that when he
first
sat the exchange we we still preaching
to the students
oh you know don't want the rooks to get
on open files don't let them open up the
game
that's why you don't when you sack an
exchange you want your pieces to get on
good squares and keep the files closed
and then one of the best players on the
planet says nah
we heard about that we're going to open
up files for your rooks like
what this was just not his finest hour
and he better hope that he can defend
this position and get out of this
alive because he's in trouble right now
one of the main
uh what's the main line i want to ask
anish after the move b3 what should he
play as black i think we we saw the
lines already the the capture on b3
capture on g3 and queen g5 was actually
the main line given by
take take and
this is where the computer
uh ignores the threat of queen c5 check
and the computer just says that well you
can march away
from here i would have to say queen b2
is such an insane movement
yeah like forcing the rook to h1 check
right like you slam down the move queen
c5 check
yeah as if it's a winner uh anticipating
that queen f2
rook h 1 is a winner yeah when i saw it
from
far away i thought the move queen d4 was
almost forced but i didn't particularly
like the move queen d4 because i thought
in an end game well i do have a pass
pawn on c6 i have a
spot on e6 three to one majority on the
clean side right yeah you don't want to
play queen d4
exactly so you were happy until you
you the kingy king f1 kind of annoyed
you
i mean in a game i would be happy but
then somebody showed me the
computer evaluation there you go
i would say if you the natural move is
actually queen
c3 then queen b2 uh if you're gonna
if you're gonna go for that trade line
right that that's what i didn't like oh
because you have rook c1 maybe at the
end hitting my c6 pawn
right if you go queen g5 queen c3 right
yeah instead of
the move queen b2 uh everybody agrees
with you that queen c3
uh much more natural to stop both queen
c5
and to threaten the c6 and i'm sorry you
were about to say alejandro
but rookie one doesn't look like it's
going to be a threat because the knight
d3
right so you still have you have to
check and after the trade well you
you brought the knight to a vulnerable
square but the problem is
yeah you're about to say rooksy won
knight d3
is oops that's a boomerang yeah i was
kind of hoping to take on c6 first but
it just doesn't work out because if you
take on c6 first
bishop takes c6 rook c1 you have this
move rook h5
defending the knight on the fifth rank
and this just doesn't work out for white
i remember when i was really
beginning chess and if i ever had a move
like rook h5 that defended something
alone
i felt like there's great deal of pride
like i had foreseen
that i could defend the the knight from
the side
that's a very nice uh point in this case
uh unfortunately i think that knight d3
also
probably still works okay but your point
is very well taken indeed
um b3 uh may i also uh be devil's ad
good for a moment because i wasn't sure
what would have happened on queen d2 i
knew i mean
b3 was a principal move i understand
but had white play queen d2 maurice i
mean
that one line that we ended up
checkmating ourselves
yeah that's pretty cool it's really
convincing to me too
and i think it went nicely c5 queen d6
knight d3 we believe yeah we took that
knight
yes we did we taking on d3 bishop takes
c6 and we kind of
thought rook d8 was
yeah if we get made it is not a good
sign but we saw queen d7 and queen b7
mate
which provoked rook d8 which god has
made it well the
engine bar looks equal so i guess we're
missing something
there must be some great defensive it's
not here
it's definitely not bishop c6 because
roxy one must be mate
yeah queen queen
queen d8 that's probably it we miss
some of these uh nasty retreating moves
and that just covers and of course
everything
golly that's i guess if it works it
works
it works it works i know lavonne uh
levon oroni in an
interview with maurice once said look
all i'm interested in
is you know just show me the move right
like and queen d8
yeah that that's the move yeah
good enough but b2 uh
b3 is rocking
onisha's world at the moment yeah how
are we doing on the time situation by
the way
maybe we can get an update on that 37
minutes for
dak 34 for initially do get an extra 30
minutes add move 40
but since there are move 24 in an
extremely sharp position still
still pretty far away from that and they
of course do get the 30
very very far away and it looks as if it
occurred to anish said
uh i'm not the only one attacking and i
might not even be the main one
attacking in fact because h4 this
demonstration he thought would give him
some play on the line
is going nowhere fast and he's just he's
just got nothing with that 96
and that bishop on b7 they're not in the
game
and in the meantime all of white's
pieces are playing and b3 is
highlighting that fact so anish now
realizes
the truth of what he's done to himself
and he is taking
yeah is some deep deep deep think right
at this moment
and with some insight into the
nuances here as well we're gonna jump to
bucharest with christian
thank you maurice uh yes i i just came
back actually from
the playing hall and i was looking
around and trying to understand the
energy that this player are providing
right now and
anish was like very very relaxed uh just
after
this move bishop to f3 before he played
this move
h4 after that after uh he played the
move h4
and uh dak responded with the move b3 he
tensed up so this is a clear sign that
anish is uh no longer
in control at this point dak we have to
be very very careful
with him because his time management
from what i know and from what i've seen
in his previous years because i've seen
this guy just
rise up and become one of the most
promising young talents
in romania the most promising young
talents in romania and
in the world to be honest because the
guy is only 19 right now
but he has these problems with uh the
time situation so we're gonna have to
keep a very close eye to that one
uh another interesting uh moment in the
game was after the move queen to
e5 that immediately played the move
bishop takes g4
he had the first option of playing this
move of
directionally going towards this move b3
with the move rook to e1 first to attack
the queen
and uh force the queen to be displaced
from the central square
e5 and after queen to g7 for example
uh or queen pretty much anywhere else
because black needs to
continue playing h5 h4 try to open up
the h file and create some
threats against the white king the
problem is
white's attack on the queen side where
the black king is
just comes so naturally and of course
after the move b3 despite the fact that
you haven't gotten
that pawn g4 well that pawn is not that
important
uh it's everything that's uh is
important right now
is speed who is going to be the first
one to reach
the other side's king and it seems like
after this b3 move
is going to be white who's going to uh
potentially get closer to that uh black
king
he didn't do that he played the move
bishop to g4 and uh
as i was mentioning as you guys were
mentioning countless of times
after queen to f6 bishop to f3
anish play this i would say careless
move
uh h4 instead of that he should have
done knight c5
redirect the knight to a better position
potentially d3
but more importantly control this break
b3 right now b3 is never going to happen
the knight is very nicely placed
surrounded by these pawns
you're going to be uh have to be to
attack that knight displace it from c5
and you're not going to play b3 anytime
soon and in the meantime black is just
going to go h4 open up the h file
and get the attack that he wants instead
of that
one tempo down he played the move h4
immediately
that took advantage with b3 and right
now anish is
tense he's in trouble guys thank you
uh christian for that insight and yeah
after b3
uh there was a good 10 15 minute think
there by anish and he did capture on b3
and we have some further moves not just
queens
capture by the way did you notice how
uh bogdan got up he pulled in a niche
a lot of what we've seen is anish making
a move and getting up
walking away from the board bogdan said
uh let me i mean
i'm the one who's better he's confident
i'm the one who's confident there he
goes he's gone
that's what is what i was telling you
guys he wears his emotions
you can tell from across the room if his
position is good or bad
and well great shot there there you go
anish is the one that's suffering
look at him deep in concentration this
is not a happy i'm concentrated trying
to kill the guy
this is uh what's going on with my
position right what did i do what did i
do
and it feels like queen g5 in order to
stop
this white queen from uh prancing queen
e3
e3 is is very nasty uh the business
square
is the d7 square for the rook if you
play a move like queen e3
and provoke king b8 then we just land on
d7
and immediately make our presence known
which is why we're thinking queen g5
sorry right it's
this important c5 square because if
you're able to play knight c5 in this
position i think
you could play call tempo yeah but the
move queen e3 i just don't think you can
answer right
exactly and you're losing a7 the knight
doesn't have a good place to go to
you don't you definitely don't want to
allow the queen to come to
a7 uh for four yeah
that said guys clearly i need screwed up
we got that part the engine's saying
better for white
all right we got that part but how
hard is it to win this position if
queens come off the board i don't think
you i i mean at that point i think we're
playing for three results
yeah no no i think it's yeah absolutely
i think the queen the white queen
is incredibly useful for damaging
black's king
you take the queens off the board then
black's king can
march to to b6 as far as i'm concerned
and if that's the case
let's get back to the queen g5 line
let's do queen g5 because
and that was we had to play queen b2 and
not
queen c3 because queen c3 allowed the
queen trade i got you but
queen queen g5 queen b3 when you are in
a little bit of time pressure with
another 14 moves to go
that's going to take a lot of gumption
to play like that i'm saying kwe g5
queen queen c3 looks like the simply
most natural move
at least okay maybe i avoid a queen
trade but the line with queen b2
queen c5 check king to f1 no it was
insanity
this i mean seriously that
that's a computer line congratulations i
want to see white
actually do this on a chessboard
this is some wild stuff to do knowing
that your king is is marching up i guess
you just say oh you're going to have
rick age one check
and it's all over rover well
yes it's it is sort of true because
queen c4
check doesn't seem to lead anywhere
after the king marches to d2
you have no more checks to look for
wow i mean i think the important thing
is the rook does no retreat square i
don't think you can possibly
take on e1 because i think back with the
king and it's actually black that's
getting mated because of the threat of
queen h8
you don't even have a very very nice
waterline queen h8
oops sorry queen h8 and queen d8 mate
what was it the opera mate on d8
something like that right
but it you would like you you would love
to retreat that rook actually to h8 so i
can swing around to d8 myself
right to give the check but you just
don't have it
it is insanity i understand that and i
think queen bee2 is extremely hard
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying yeah the engine can point out
this move and you say oh yeah right
okay yeah that's the way to play but
sitting there as a player with your
clock ticking
minutes going you you go will he find
queen b2 that's a super difficult move
given the line that validates the
quality of it
right queen we understand that the queen
should go on this diagonal after queen
g5 has
the black queen vacates that long
diagonal then it's natural
for white to vacate it that's basic you
know aikido chest if you will drawback
chest but as you look at it queen g5
not only do you have to do you take over
the diagonal you also
in full aikido mode by the way say
i want you to carry out your greatest
threat which is queen c5
like i actually want you to do it i
don't want to stop it with queen c3
i actually want you to do it i'm
encouraging it and
carry out the threat go ahead queen c5
check king f1
rook h1 check king to e2
as we follow queen to c4 check keep
doing everything you really want to do
and you will likely get crushed
as we get to the point with your attack
and
speaking of attacking players we have
one of the legends of the game sitting
with us right now
we're actually with christian in
bucharest
none other than gary kasparov
thank you very much maurice i'm here
with a legend of our game a man that
needs absolutely no introduction the 13
world champion gary kasparov an
innovator
an entrepreneur and the mastermind
behind the grand chess tour uh gary
welcome
to the show how are you feeling about
the game so far how do you feel to see
uh the granchester finally take center
stage in the world of chess after
a year and a half hiatus yeah i had a
very strange you know
impression when i was at stage today i
made the first move in the uh
rajab of carolina game that i mean some
of the players they are not very
comfortable you know moving from
from the comfort the studies to the
stage though i think four players here
they play the rather the candidates
uh in russia but still there's some kind
of you know just i think discomfort so
this is this they
because now they have that stage you
know it's it's very different they have
to see their opponent
because it's the when you play online so
you just you can
you can be very emotional but you know
that your opponent is not is not uh
looking at you so here is different and
i and i
think that is that it's a very quiet
start so it's
with uh three quick draws it's somehow
the result that you know they
they have to get adjusted it just sounds
odd you know this is the the
professional players
they have to be adjusted you know to
play games over the board but
those are those are the realities and i
think it will pick up it will pick up
now and
at least we have a couple of games that
are interesting definitely this one
still some very interesting fights
yes this is yeah um and uh again i
uh i think it's it's very important that
we you know we're back on stage because
uh uh with all due respect to
to um the fighting spirit of of
strongest players
uh who had to compete over the last uh
uh
15 months or so online it's still
different
it's still different and i think nothing
can be compared to the
to this atmosphere of suspense and and
the emotional atmosphere that you can
you can feel while you are
in the playing call or even you are
watching you know online
but players are life so that's part
again it's a real game so you have two
players you know facing each other
we have down this is the it's the
leaning player they're
facing geary and uh which is quite
interesting because
i don't think that um if not for for
tournament and bucharest plus covet
that the romanian players will have a
chance to face the the
uh world top players because you know we
you know that's the the grant store is
back but unfortunately
not all the players are back and uh we
just had to deal with this uh
harsh reality of covet but it's well
it's like it's they're always winners
and losers the
uh some of the players could make it
like that ding or vichanand
uh uh eventual report got sick uh
but still the it's a big big win for
managers
and uh you know who knows maybe oh wow
just as we
as as as i spoke these words
geary made just a very poor move and uh
it might be
you know a sensational start so it's the
again as i said you know somebody's
winning somebody's losing and it seems
that gear is uh
is not uh was not up to after the
challenge he's probably expecting his
romanian counterpart to uh collapse on
his own but nobody collapsed on his own
speaking of opportunities
yesterday during the opening ceremony uh
you mentioned that there's still that
itch whenever you see these players
compete against each other
will we ever have an opportunity to see
you back um
look again i'm an amateur or so now as
you know i just
but i still remember how to move the
pieces so and i i will definitely
play the 916 saint louis that's it
that's the
tradition now again i don't expect much
you know from my my performance and
uh and i'm also uh um uh planning to
to as a croatian national to to play
part of the part of the event uh in in
zagreb so on a bleed section so that's
this is we
that's the plan is that we'll share with
uh with uh our wizard showrich
uh who will play the rapids and i will
just you know uh play play
play the blitz blitz blitz segment you
know just uh uh feeling feeling the
the um the spot for creation uh for
creation local player
so i guess yeah i'd say yeah it's uh
again it's fun so
i i hope i will i will be able just to
to play a couple of good games though
again i just don't have
high expectations but you know it's uh
it's as i said yesterday
it's uh you know when i see the players
uh you know moving the pieces and just
you know when i
sense this emotion you know behind each
move so yeah it's
it's something that the passion that
doesn't doesn't go away and uh
and i'm always very happy just to to to
be part of this
of the uh the commentaries because it's
it's a chance to
to share my experience and uh and my
um my views about
both about the games but also about the
grunges tour event and about chess in
general and about online chess
with with a very broad very wide
audience a lot of things
have changed in the past year and a half
and some things have changed for you as
well
you've become an entrepreneur a ceo of a
new company tell us a little bit
i'm not done my name on on the title
doesn't mean that i'm
running the company so let's let's let's
let's separate two things absolutely
yes i you know i i i've been working
with
with
vivendi and also with uh with the
grunge's tour so
to uh to launch this new site kasparov
chess.com
so it's it's it's a venture uh between
the the
french french companies led by vivendi
and and
and um and granchester
and i thought it would be unique
opportunity
to uh bring something new so it's we
know that
world of chess now has several very
powerful platform so
just name two uh uh chess.com and just24
now known as magnus chess
but i still think you know there's
there's a room there's a room and uh
what this thing is missing is is the
combination of education entertainment
yes we know that chess.com has you know
it's it's excellent you know playing
zone we know that
chess 24 has you know very powerful
broadcast system and of course
magnus is the biggest attraction but you
know it's
a lot of people you know they would like
to learn and also to be entertained
that's what we
learned from the queen's gambit the
success of the queen's gambit and i
think that's work as part of chess could
easily compete or maybe even surpass the
our competitors
because we we have you know a very broad
range of lessons
and also it's not just similar lessons
you know but it's more you know just
it's in in a fashion that makes people
comfortable and
and i'm planning to to add to to the
hundreds and hundreds of lessons that
have been already recorded
um at by doing a new master class
so from here i'm going to france and
i'll spend few days in the in the studio
recording a brand new masterclass so the
one that i did
in 2017 actually instead lewis was a
master class with this company so it was
very successful
but it was
it was still missing you know the um
the clear targeting because it's the
the those the those who directed the
program they had no idea so how to
actually make lessons um
adjustable to different different
segments of the chess audience
and this time you know we will be
learning from from
that master class and we'll be adding uh
the uh the grades
so uh by the way this is we already have
this inside inside caspar chess.com
so the eight different categories from
the beginners to master so basically
from uh uh one thousand to twenty two
hundred so that's
uh that's when you just look for the
lessons when you just look for uh for
the puzzles
uh but uh my my master class will be
divided in three
three major categories you know the the
beginners the
advanced players and semi-professional
players and
and i think it's it will be again it's a
new step in in combining the
entertaining
and and and education and learning
and also i think we we can do more by
creating community
community factor is very important and
while again this is every
platform as a community i still think it
more can be done and get here which we
will try to
to outpace our opponents well thank you
for sharing the vision and actually you
were mentioning community
one of the most brilliant things that i
enjoyed about the platform
were the podcast style conversations you
had tell us a little bit about that and
how are you
enjoying that i will be doing more you
know it's it's uh um
it's it's again it's very important to
tell stories because
what again going back to the quiz gambit
so it's the
people want to hear stories so it's not
just you know
just chess moves or just listen it's
important who is telling you the story
so
and it's something about emotional
response and
again here i think we can we can add
value
so it's and the reason the podcast was
very successful is because it's a true
story it's just you know it's a
it's not the story that is brushed it's
all the story that you know it's it's
it's it's not a hollywood story
it's from the source but also this it's
the the success of the queen's gambit
was very much due to the fact that
it was not a class typical hollywood
story it's just you know it had the
element a raw element so with the
uh um it had authenticity and
i you know i'm quite proud that i could
i could contribute to make to make it
more authentic
uh authentic and i think that's uh it's
the uh what we'll be doing as part of
jazz and what i do with with podcasts
is again it's bringing personality into
into the story
it's it's so important it's it's not a
nameless person you know a great expert
who is sitting i don't know
god knows in in frankfurt in oslo in san
francisco in moscow
in in in mumbai and and
telling you move you know bishop there
pawn there no it's a story so
it's it's a context it's it's it's
adding this element of interactivity
which is so important today now and
and i i could feel that you know uh
there's more can be done
but but here we have our competitive
edge speaking uh once again about
growing the community
what do you feel about personal players
brand and how important is that to grow
the community and bring new fans into
the game
oh i think it's very important you know
this is the it's it's uh fan club is you
know
as you know it's a part of every every
successful commercial activity
uh and and we have personalities i think
it's very important to
to to uh to cater it and also to
to promote it and uh and again more
more more can be done so but it's also
you know
it's also important the players
recognize it so it's it's that's
they're no longer you know so the to a
passive follower so
they create product analysis and and
hopefully they can do you they can more
by
by making this product more attractive
more personal more
again entertaining and um
and i hope that you know this is the the
standards we are now establishing this
quick sport of chess would be very
helpful because we have this concept
concept of ambassadors ambassadors of
the gay of of
uh kasparov chess that will you know
that will
uh uh use their um
fame and their ability to to uh
to tell the tell the
white audience about chess that's the
and teach people
but they will do it in a way that is uh
it's could um
could bring them much closer to doing
this again it's this is you don't want
to
to look aloof you know that you're just
you you have you know
it's it's not about just teaching it's
about you know just entering this the
the living room and and being part of
this of this
uh um exercise and again that's still
that's somehow
you know that's that's uh i was a lesson
of the pandemics
because that's that's what people
looking for and that's what we're going
to provide
that's a great vision with a lot of
energy behind it uh
let's hop into the analysis what's
happening here
look it's the uh it wasn't a
natural choice that's that's of geary
just to
play you know um very aggressive opening
show and uh
andy again this is the remaining
counterpart
who was definitely was viewed as
underdog in the game he
he picked up the challenge sacrificed
the pawn so and
he had some decent compensation i'm not
sure giri played
this is his hand well do you think he's
taking more risks than he
you know the last move is just a queen
g7 is just you know it looks
uh very odd to me so i definitely i
think this
black had to try to play queen g5 you
know just here or just it's the
because they have to try to exchange
queens i think that's the exchanging
queens you know that's that's probably
you know will
will give them you know just a
reasonable position so that's the
again i still think white is white as
white is better here so
i don't know maybe maybe queen b2 now
that's what computer says so maybe
yeah with queen c5 king f1 oh come on
this is just a run with a key yeah but
but you know but that's the that's this
something like yeah king of one
so it doesn't feel like a human move
look at this
again is it why why does it white is
better here but it's but but if you go
back to the game so i just think
after g4 i just don't understand what's
what's what's
gear is looking for so i think it's
black black um
i don't know just what's his i wonder
what would be his next move
after after after g4 so it's the um
knight c7
queen also d3 it's
unless you know white blood or something
so it's just the game as we say for two
results either white wins or it's or
gears
escapes so i still can you know hardly
imagine that you will lose the game but
you never know it just says
what about the time timing is about the
time is about the same i think giri has
more time than what it shows there i
think 10 minutes extra
but it's the i wonder why why you know
why deck is just is
spend so much time because g4 is so
natural so just the pawn is attacked you
just push the pawn pawns protected by
the bishop
uh so what's the what's wrong with g4
and it's
not always nice you know just to push
the pawn for the end game
potentially i think the end game will be
inevitable so i can hardly imagine black
can
escape you know with each but black
should probably strive for the end game
yeah but this is this yeah this is but
um
yeah still strive for the end game still
you know this is that's the
f7 pawn line might be too weak yeah yeah
potentially yes
but um so one is definitely in trouble
in this one let's see what's uh
happening in this one if there's
anything happening at all
doesn't seem likely look it's it's it's
uh
queen's getting accepted with uh with
you know dc5 which is by the way this is
the
this move it's not you know it's not uh
such a nokia's move uh kramnik played it
several times against myself so i these
are these they're always you know
they're always potential problems for
black but they have to be very cautious
but
i don't think as they they just you know
they the way he played
yeah i think i think kramnik played
against me once played 95
95 in uh in uh um
uh linares so i uh managed to make a
draw but i just i was worse
uh and and the way just they played is
just it's
i don't know i just it's the doesn't
seem like he brought too much uh
novelty let's say into the game maybe
you could have neither three keep more
pieces on the board yeah maybe just
maybe just you know keep more pieces on
board so
because this knight on c6 is not well
placed so it's maybe you know then
you can because the whole idea is
actually you have to try to harass the
bishop on this diagonal this is and uh
because the king is here so that's why
if you can go tonight's potentially
knight on c3 knight on a4
so something like this and as long as
the bishop goes on this time
you have this exactly true if you go
kingdom knight a4 and
either you i don't know just it's the
either you give me this diagonal or you
okay yeah you should go here and uh
that's probably
still now it seems that seems that it's
no
still something to work with but very
close to
equality now it seems to me that it's
yeah maybe 92 here i don't know just
maybe b5 was just you know potentially
it's good because
the weekend and hopefully i can just try
to bring my knight on c4 and
yeah i think white is slightly better
here but it's just
yeah it's the yeah but in the game it's
just it seems that you know this they
it was everything was exchanged and uh
and i yeah why this
might be looking like he's going in but
there's nothing happening really
yeah but okay this is still probably now
but it should be six years but what do
you go with a knight now b3 or c6
i would probably go to c6 but then king
d6 and that's what you put tonight
with c6 the king g8 and then
so what's uh yeah that's the i don't
know
that seems seems like that draw so maybe
you can
you can go i don't know maybe
but what would the white plant be in
this position go a4 and try to
open up i don't know
i don't know maybe we can go e5 and then
king b6
maybe just king into kingdom six even
seems like a very dry situation at this
point
very very dry situation so let's maybe
try game four i don't know but this is
but no i think it's a draw i think it's
just that's that's what i feel
now we should probably concentrate on
geari game yep so this is absolutely
let's oh queen d3
queen d3 and uh 1967 yeah
okay what he wanted to attack instantly
so was there
so he did not take on g3
because he was afraid of with tekken
they couldn't have seven percent i think
it's just you know and just take one f7
yeah yeah but that's that's the
difference now now the end games all
other games will be lost so that's very
eerie
because of the weakness but also g-pawn
now it's a past pawn
look you know this was double opponent
you know that's that was a solid one e6
is weak and uh
and you know not knight is no match for
the rook in the open
open position so it's the queen d3
knight c7
so um
i'm expecting probably he's going to try
to defend this pawn on g3 like this
which is natural he'll defend the pawn
and also attack this pawn
we'll see so maybe just yeah
definitely seems like doc is in a poor
position to maybe score the first
victory in this one
what's going on i wouldn't i wouldn't no
not so not so fast not so fast
so not so fast i still think you know
gary and giri
has defensive resources and uh but um
it's very interesting to see so if uh
if giri has nerves to defend his
position because this is definitely what
he didn't expect
so when he played this opening and he
got his extra pawn and
he thought it just it's he would he
would
uh not have a hard time by defending his
potential threats and and then you know
just
uh collecting a point and uh
that's um might be might be a big blow
to me
it's definitely uh going to be a battle
of nurse as we get closer to time
control uh thank you very much he did
i don't know no no no no he hasn't
played it yeah yes okay i just i'm
i'm curious so let's just this is so we
this is the position yes
yes 97 still it's the same obviously
he's still he's still still thinking
that's well let's wait until he makes a
move yes i just i'm curious you know
whether he plays
g4 or queen d6 absolutely absolutely no
i think
g4 g4 what's up maybe g4 maybe knight
goes here yes
that's the and then you take
you take and then you should take and
then
still you know let's see this is check
somehow
giving that bishop doesn't feel very
natural check
maybe rook c7
i don't know just it's um even here
even here black is but probably it's
just maybe somehow it's a
bishop is still locked here yeah a bit
of a log but it's this it's this is not
no you don't need it just no i think
it's just
it's the you know we you know when the
queen is much better because you don't
want
you don't want knight d5 so because of
the queen the 695
you simply take on the five let's check
this yeah we'll be
yeah we'll check mate so uh we'll uh see
if this
is very natural move you know sometimes
you know the moves that are so natural
that's you know that's what you probably
do in bullets so they just uh
i wonder if he may be considering czech
and then queen d6
overthinks his decision yeah i just you
know just two i meant to pin
the night i don't know which is i think
also possible
because it's just queen is very very you
know annoying there
so maybe that's the that's that's that's
is
um okay so it does feel there's still a
lot of work to be done for uh for the
young buck let's say to convert this one
look but i'm sure he's also nervous now
this is just this yeah
it's it's his first game at the
tournament of that level he's
facing one of the top players in the
world and uh and
he knows his is uh
a decent player to understand that he's
close speaking of that
which one was your first let's say
opportunity or which one
is the one that you remember uh an
opportunity to play with the top
players of the era what tournament it
depends depends what do you say top
you know players in new york it's uh
because in the soviet union we uh we
also had these events you know with
grand masters giving simultaneous
exhibitions
so that's why you know when i was 10 you
know i
as a member of uh of baku pioneer team
so
i was part of the competition moscow and
i i had a chance of playing talpol
avrerbach because mean so
that's that was uh in 1974 in march
and in 1975 i played another tournament
as
as already uh captain of our team from
baku we qualified again
and i faced uh you know carpool and
culture so that's my first game with the
world champion was 1975. i was
just 12. and so um
and also i had you know experience at
home but again
depends what is the what is the famous
player in baku you know
we had very different scale of
evaluation so i i think that's the
my first victory over at top um
player local player was actually
incident it's
one of my podcasts um local master like
pavlenko it was the
at that time called rapid chess one hour
game just you know no of course
increments
uh and uh it was a cup of baku
uh city cup and i
made it to the final so just instead by
winning the two games two games and then
blitz type breaks and i i managed to to
get through without i break so and
and in the final i faced uh much
stronger player and i managed to win the
match so that's the
you may call us that was a um a big
victory
yeah and also it was the first
appearance of gary kasparov because you
know i changed my
family name uh in the summer uh summer
1975. so
it's the it's the first time when gary
gasparov appeared as the as a winner
so uh that's uh that was what
october 1975. there we have it
how important do you feel it is to give
these young players the opportunity to
face
top players top opposition look it's
always
it's always no it's important that you
have your chance to
to test yourself against strong
opponents uh
look it's we all know it's important but
you still need a chance because
there are not so many tournaments yes
and then limited number of seats and i
think romanian employees are very lucky
they have they have such you know such a
generous sponsor that is just
doing this event now i believe
traditional event
and and with the support of super bet
you know the romanian players they had
this you know just the opportunity they
couldn't dream of
and and hopefully now with more you know
more um
expansion of the game of chess i know
the super bit has plans to
move with him so
albania will will see more talented
players but but i think that's it
if he wins so that's this is it's the
though again anything can happen in the
game if he wins
he did play the movie yeah that would be
a big boost
that would be a big boost because that's
what people need you know so it's not
that
they were lucky to uh get in but it's uh
they proved to be worthy of uh this
uh this effort to bring them in and uh i
think gear
facing a real challenge now i uh i don't
know i'm
i still be surprised if he loses but uh
but uh
oh now now what did he play now he plays
c5 and it's
it looks bad to me so that's that's the
now uh
yeah big moment it seems like rookie
five seems to be winning
yeah by the rookie five but this is
interesting because it's the
that's the um rookie five
and i think after q3 i think this this
is this this is what he gets h5
is over yeah yeah that's the stuff
h5 yes i was right yes who guess rook h5
yes book h5 and it seemed that we have
uh
yeah that's that's his material here so
hook h5 wing instantly
so uh so after rookie five
that's it what to do bishop three is the
65 came over so
so uh now that's that's a moment that's
the moment of truth
huge moment huge moment so rookie five i
don't know is deck a good
uh tactical player so this is this is
the moment
for him to make history he's an
all-around very decent player
one of his big problems is going into
time travel so as long as he avoids that
um but okay this is the time trouble is
after if he finds rookie five
it's probably you know even even one on
the clock might be enough so as the
if he finds rookie five but the key is
rook if i could just rook h5
yeah that's that's that's important you
know just the moment you see the idea so
you just you know you
you uh you play rookie five but uh giri
just definitely doesn't see it because
it's just
it's the uh otherwise you played c5
and uh and i wonder if if he if that
will be five so what are the other
options
i'm curious if you take on c5 probably
the bishop of three bishop takes f3 is
going to be
over it's not nothing and then after
rook c1 then
f5 and this queen queen is protecting so
um take on b7 just doesn't make much
sense
because you have to follow up with queen
takes c5 but that drops the point
exactly doesn't make sense so
it seems that rookie five is the is this
is the only
only only only yes decent move
which happens to be winning as well yeah
so it's the
yeah wow what a moment now big moment
what a moment what a big moment now
for uh for romanian chess for that yes
actually he
is representing the hopes and dreams of
romanian trust he became a grandmaster
when he was 14.
he's definitely one of the top talents
in the world right now
at only 19 years of age well uh
gary thank you very much okay thank you
for joining us i'm leaving you at such a
moment of suspense but uh oh we would
love to keep
as much as possible i just will uh no
look you know i'm just i
i'm still very passionate i just want to
see what happens whatever happens you
know i
i promise i i'll walk away so the moment
he makes a move absolutely no no no
no no no no no no that is just we said
the routing is yes
whispering rookie five we'll be carrying
all these visions and all this
analysis with us it's a blessing for us
so yeah but i'm here so i'll be just you
know i
i'll be here every day in studio so
that's why you know i uh
uh i think except the the last the last
round
oh definitely yes yes yes uh
last two rounds so on and uh um
and i'm sure there will be more more
interesting games but that's good
good news because sometimes you have you
know you have uh events were just you
know that totally
just uh they they they
like a faceless i mean there's nothing
still nothing nothing
nothing is happening at all and uh and
at least here we have by the way
anything happening there
doesn't feel like it no no it's still
ah no it's uh this one is gonna draw
most likely yes yes this is the
yeah this is this is the game this is
the game oh man
yes do we have any other moves like no i
mean this is
the this is you know this is a problem
you know that's this it's no other move
you know comes from close because you
know that's this
black the black managed to escape to to
exchange this bad bishop when
they have two pawns and the king is open
by the bishop also plays an important
role protecting the kings
um and then just you know they they are
okay they just
they after rook to e5 what about
moving the bishop to d5 just take it
what do you just take you know this on
d5 here simply so it's good to do oh
yeah
i cannot take with the pawn because
rookie seven yeah
no this is uh this is not looking good
c5 and uh
rookie five there's no other eternity
for black no no this is it's just you
know it's
attacked total domination queen of faith
maybe
could afraid then uh i don't understand
just going to the end game
yeah no they're not just you know that's
probably yes it's the yeah take rook c5
bishop gf okay that's that's easy
yeah that's easy so that's again that's
the there's an end game but
with you know was without without c pawn
so it was the
we talked about this is going to be a
shocker if
if he plays rocky 5. will he
i don't know
i think but it's it's you know easy we
look at this the position now
you know we we can discuss it you know
just in the comfort of the
studio so the engine engine helps us a
little bit they'll kind of since rookie
five is very natural
but he's there he what would you know
it's if
if you know this is important if if he
knows that there's a win
then he finds it but he doesn't know he
doesn't win exactly this is
this is a trick so sometimes you don't
even have to
to to to uh offering an advice basically
all you need is just to to to
record and go telling you no yes to that
there is a win
find it find it how is this end game
because i would assume okay
let's say he misses rook h5 how is this
endgame
it's still pretty good it's it's still
yeah it's it's it's white white is much
better and could be an idea to bail out
just in case there's nothing else just
going to the end game yeah by the way
you're right yes it's
it's so it's even if he doesn't see
queen h5 so
yeah so he's just that's that's good
enough yeah because that's you know you
exchange you can you exchange this
c pawn on g pawn you know so the keys
bishop of five take on a free is
impossible so that's why
that's why uh yeah you asked a good
question why he's thinking
about rookie five even this end game is
very good somehow all
routes point uh to a rookie five it's
obvious from our perspective of course
but
because it brings the rook there the
rook if you look
here this is this is the the only pip
the piece that is not playing so the
bishop is
is already in the game queen is in the
game rook d
rook on defiles in the game so rook on e
file
is still you know just waiting to be
brought into the action yeah so and
of course you know rookie five is is an
action so um
he's already spent 11 minutes left at
least according to uh to this one
yeah it's not actually curious maybe we
can see it
yeah he does have 11 minutes on the
board
and give me 21. yeah is he sitting there
so
he's not he's not i'm sure he's knows
that he's losing
somehow just i feel that giri
yeah he's calculating it he's definitely
looking at something
uh it's a big moment and i think he
knows it i think he knows it he's been
spending the last what eight minutes
for this move let me have a look
rookie five he's looking at rookie five
i can tell you
he's looking rookie five i just you know
i see the eyes so that's he looks at e5
square
so uh the laser eyes yeah yeah what is
look at e5 square so now
so i think his question is he's probably
covered in
the end game but yes he's looking at
rookie five
yeah yeah uh yeah big big big big moment
anything else outside of rookie f5 no no
no
the fact is there's nothing else that
you know you can
i mean you play g4 no i don't
think so g4 no no
any other choice it doesn't seem like it
king f2 to defend the pawn on cheese
no other natural options exactly that's
that's that's the deal of new ones yeah
so
maybe queen e5 but no just yeah
yeah it's but it's the same but then
just you know you take 95 so this is the
yeah all the changes in 95 and the
knight is on the center
yeah still your move
yeah um yeah well it seems like uh
10 more minutes and we're going to find
out well probably less than that
hopefully less than that because if he
gets in this time travel
it's close
not not very eventful game what can i
say
no no no no no yeah tell us a little bit
about the partnership between
um the saint louis chess club the
granchester and casper of chess
and uh casper chess is a part of it it
is yes so i'm there uh
i'm there as the as the as the
uh sort of uh brain behind the area and
also yeah bring my you know my name and
experience and it will begin this is the
i will be definitely spending a
considerable amount of time on the
platform to make sure that you know
let's people know that
i'm not there just by name but by all
physical presence yeah so
yeah and uh and uh grant's tour is is
is a vital part because you know we
believe that you know this the that's
now
it's the most important uh professional
event um
series of events it has a history so
obviously you know the other events now
this is we know that magnus is
organizing his online events
but um no you cannot do online all the
time so
and while the calendar is is always
filled with many events so branches tour
has its reputation it's just you know
so many years and and we
plan you know our our expansion so and
uh
and naturally now we have already you
know strongholds
it's uh counting from from west to east
so it's
said louise paris and now bucharest and
we believe that zagreb also will join
you know as the as the traditional event
so it's uh
so what do you know a solid solid ground
for future expansions
and so we'll you know how difficult was
the process to uh
get it back on track well it's um
it was just a waiting period because we
you know we uh
had everything ready last year and
then we just had to make make an
adjustments um
as everybody else had to so it was not
it was not just you know us
so which is everybody had to go through
the same very painful
uh an annoying process of
changing changing dates
and we just you know all we did is as we
know we started the same
grunges tool but we had losses that we
couldn't predict because you know this
is the
the covert restrictions um uh four stars
forced us to uh to make change after
change so that's what's so difficult to
make all announcements because you know
it
says
what can you do if all of a sudden you
have an india the album you know just uh
it's a new wave and then we shan uh oh
no
yeah yeah let's see yep
yep so i as i said i walk away so thank
you thank you
thank you gary pleasure and honor guys
back to you
thank you very much christian and gary
gary
passionate but the big news out of that
entire thing
croatia on amazing you heard it here
first
guys gary kasparov the legend
the former world champion known in the
internet as
gary chaz the inventor of chess he will
be playing the blitz
the blitz section of the cro asia
grand chess tour ivan sarge will be the
representative of croatia in
the rapid portion what an amazing
lineup we're going to have everybody's
going to be watching welcome gary
what big news do we have in the game a
long wait
but bogdan diack was unable to find the
move
rook e5 geary is right back in the game
and guys
i am worried about that clock yeah after
a long think over queen d7 rookie five
in every line we were looking at we were
just getting more enthusiastic for
white's position
anish was toast after rook e5 he didn't
play the move rook e5 he played queen d7
check
king b8 bishop takes and king takes
what is the clock situation clock
situation is eight
minutes for dak and counting i believe
the idea of him is to play rook takes e6
in this position it's a very nice
double pin cannot take with the f pawn
because the queen is hanging
and you cannot take with the knight
because that is illegal
this still looks dangerous i'm not going
to lie rookie if i was convincing
still i wouldn't say that he's reaching
his reaching for the pawn
i wouldn't say that anish is out of the
water perhaps he's not losing
but he still can't be thrilled with the
position he has on the board well after
rook takes e6
maurice uh jump in uh water's fine here
rook takes e6 that's not a that that's
not
a clincher knights are notorious for
being able to defend as he smashed
rook takes e6 one of the great
sacrifices for rooks in chess by the way
i consider it the greatest of all
sacrifices for rooks in chess you can
compete with me on this one where uh
what other square
can you sacrifice a rook that's more
exciting than the e6 square
those are where the money sacrifices are
but unfortunately in this case
this knight on c7 is incredible we know
knights next to kings can be incredible
defenders
and there are no easy paths toward the
black king in this position it's a
smashing move
indeed but we see the bar
on the side saying not so much
it's not the end of the world for black
what would have been the end of the
world
was in this previous position where we
were all waiting on
after c5 excuse me queen d6 c5
a massively horrible move should have
been met by
rook to e5 and that would have been a
bone cruncher if there ever was one
because bishop takes
on f3 would have led to rook takes on c5
and two rooks will end up you play a
move for example
like f5 uh any move here i guess
captures would be simple enough and
you've got
a tremendous game your positions just
co-cut busted
in this position no problems here but
rook c5 the key point sorry rook to e5
the key point
he might have missed queen takes and now
rook to
h5 hitting the queen hitting the rook
all threats on the back row still alive
this would have been toast as gary and
christian were pointing out
this has just been completely completely
over
i think guys that he never saw rookie
five
i believe that in this position after c5
i think he probably was studying queen
d7
he probably instantly spotted the move
he played he instantly saw a queen d7
and this combination and thought wow
is this enough should i go in this route
and spent all his time
analyzing and then convince himself that
the way to play
was just like this as we saw in the game
he saw this entire line got to this
position and
calculated some more and rookie five
probably never
occurred to him because if it did a
player of his class
would have been able to find find the
crushing blow rook
to h5 that's a problem in chess a lot of
times there are different ways to go
and even this way looks appealing until
you really get deep into it
and say wait a minute am i really
winning here
and it turns out that you're not so
that's a
issue with chess i think even as gary
has said if you told him there was a
wind
he might have thought this was the win
as well because it does look kind of
sexy
being able to sacrifice on e6 and crash
through near the king
it just turns out that it doesn't work
chess can be unfair aleandro
i mean rookie six does have that element
compelling right because the double
pin as you were pointing out the pawn on
f7 can't move the knight on c7 can't
move
aren't i just winning a pawn versus rook
e5 which
really is the bone crusher i have to
echo maurice it's a sexy move you get
attracted
it doesn't necessarily work out and in
this case it just seems that anish
is escaping by the skin of his teeth
let's take a look at some
actual variations queen c6 check on the
border king retreated to b8 which in my
opinion looks much more logical than
c8 where the knight is already pinned
the thing is
if you don't have a check in this
position queen h2
is going to be a huge amount of counter
play queen f4 is also going to be on tap
the king on g1 not very safe i don't
think it's going to get ever
made it but i don't see how it escapes
perpetually so for example rook e7 let's
get our rook off of pre
now that the pawn is threatening to
capture the rook
okay we're trying to keep the the the
knight
uh at home because of made on b7
and you're mentioning check and mike
king
is going to take a walk i guess after a
move like queen f4 is that
uh the point where are you walking too
i'm not sure
that's the other problem am i running
into your arms or
uh how does it go after for example king
e2
i think with this amount of time i think
it's just you're playing too much with
fire
exactly i don't even really know what
white's threat is
like if i just pass exactly i'm not like
crashing through on c7 with your queen
defending
at the night evaluation
maurice is it
even is it better white
how does the computer vow if you ask me
to check the computer it's triple zeros
or yeah
as usual oh this one is just a draw
because because like
the king's exposed and you're not doing
anything you're not
crashing through the king's exposed the
material is still even you're not
winning material and the queen is able
to attack
that we're not saying anything special
the engine's not saying anything
special in this position i'm wondering
though however
there's two things i'm wondering a
can black will black end up winning this
game
because white knowing that he was
winning overpresses
i know it sounds far-fetched because
it's like how like look at this position
right only white can win but when you
miss there's something about chance when
you say chess isn't fair justin
sometimes be brutally unfair like
brutally so
yeah you didn't do what you were
supposed to do and now something
happened oh
oh man yeah you messed it up and now
you're going to lose
what that's how 2790 beats 26 20.
all right assuming he doesn't lose and
he draws the game and then some
joker says oh oh um
grandmaster deck um you know you could
have played ricky five you would have
won the game
what will that screw him up for the
rest of the tournament knowing from
round one
he had the biggest win maybe of his
career
grand chess tour all of romania watching
and they
now know that he's screwed up and he's
gonna have to play that in his mind over
and over again
this is a big moment for this young man
let's hope he overcomes all that and
maybe the result is a positive one
but right now what we know as far as
geary's concerned is gary
let out a breath because he no doubt saw
rookie five
was killing him yeah and by the way
anisha if i've got this right has not
actually automatically played
the move king b8 which i personally find
surprising
i i'm loath to walk into a self pin
and king c8 just feels completely wrong
to my way of thinking so king b8 would
have been played
quickly by myself especially considering
the time situation still
we are on move 32 eight moves to make uh
in a very sharp position kind of want to
preserve
that time right and especially when
my opponent is the one actually uh
behind on the clock or a head on the
clock
what would be an advantage of king ca
let's look at it from that perspective
okay let's
let's imagine we're going to make an
argument that king c8 is in fact
black's best move why could we make such
an argument i have no idea
because after rookie 7 i'm thinking that
i might
even have rook take c7 and queen a8
ideas
now that your a8 square isn't defended
and of course you've
walked into a pin on c8 is it the same
thing we can uh check on h2 and then
queen f4
and queen f4 maybe there's no big
difference uh anish
very precisely trying to calculate the
difference between king b8 and king c8
certainly uh some kind of subtlety
perhaps
in some end game that instead of playing
the move rookie seven i play queen d6 to
try to exchange the queen's question
mark
like here with the rook still on e6
i can play the queen e6 because you
don't have a check right
right exactly so you probably have to
trade now
crazy for me one of the players who
actually
tormented himself with these questions
is king c8 better than king v8 with
victor korchner
and victor would really you know force
himself to come up with some answer
and if that took him an hour he would
spend the hour
it was really really crazy and i'm
sitting there saying why didn't you play
king b8 right away
and he would be like well king c8 there
is the subtle difference and
anish maybe from the victor korchner
school of chess
me i'm much more practical yeah i would
have played here
practical sometimes a little too
practical yes
sometimes
that's right so it's it's this balance
that you have
in every game of chess where do you
spend your time
how much detail do you want to get from
your moves it's funny that you should
put it like that because i asked boris
baskey the same question i actually
really really admired boris baskey even
though he was the player
lost to bobby fischer and catapulted
bobby fischer to fame
and he explained to me did boris that
the difference between himself
and you know his contemporaries to put
it like that
is that the world champions uh
sensed the critical moments they just
had this understanding that
oops let me stop myself from making my
force natural move
and consider the position so he said
that he had a very very good feel for
the critical moment
well that's and it was true it's very
true you know
for that specifically yeah absolutely
it's an art and it's not an easy one it
seems that gary
has made his decision he has put the
king on b8
which more or less expected as dr
elod from vancouver bc would say
same move faster
i just love that quote every time i
get a chance to use it yes almost
immediately dak plays the move
queen d6 offering i think forcing
the queen exchange i really don't think
you can move the queen off the diagonal
because then you start running into rook
e7
and at the same time with the queen on
d6 it's really
a great defensive uh queen as well it's
very irritating i think you have to take
on d6 i really don't see a choice
and let's take a look at this ending
okay
man well it's two pawns
it's a past c pawn that will be no they
don't c4
but this knight is just not very good
it's not it really is not and
that knight would love to have a nice
square d5 but like you just said
with the pawn on c5 it's not coming to
d5
maybe it's coming to e6 and probably
probably should right yeah i was about
to say i mean if you don't play knight
to e6 these pawns
could easily become really weak
instantly like rook to c6 and rook d7
i think white's agenda by the way do you
trade rooks as white
i think you do look do you check oh i
think that if you gave me a chance i
would
immediately take the rooks off the of
the board and the reason as
white of course the reason and this is a
normal thing for all of you
chess fans out there that play yourself
when you are down the exchange
or when you have compensation for the
exchange
very often you want to preserve your
last remaining rook
it's a very common rule of thumb there
are exceptions of course
but in i would say 90 of cases you're
down the exchange
you have a pawn you have two pawns don't
trade off
your last remaining rook that remaining
work is important to coordinate
i think that the f7 pawn in this
position is just too weak
i think that i have to figure out a way
to avoid both rooks hitting f7
but if i trade the rooks this one of the
remaining rook by white will simply pick
up the pawn on f7 and that g pawn will
simply be unstoppable
we'll see the power of a rook over a
night where he can easily stop the c
pawn and it will just take forever uh
for this clumsy knight to stop the g
pawn himself so i i think rook date is a
huge threat
i'm liking your move knight e6 because
it immediately stops to move rogue d8
um double edge end game honestly i would
rather
be white though i feel the same right
i i like the power of the rooks
especially if
you can imagine a situation like this
where you ever get a chance
to double the rooks and you've got these
back ranked mating threats
white for choice and such in such a
position
uh double-edged ending maurice jump
right in
and i would i would continue this
argument with rookie six
that that bogdan saw this
all the way back when he first played
queen d7 right agreed
right right that this is why he was
sitting there so long
analyzing he saw the queen capturing on
g3 he wanted to make sure there were no
easy drawing opportunities
with queen h2 queen f4 and the
harassment of the king
and this queen d6 move just had to
validate that this was going to be okay
because he could see
the rook is hanging on e6 but it's not
quite hanging this cute move queen to d6
which no doubt gary saw as well and
that's why he was contemplating
should he go to b8 or c8 because of the
upcoming
end game because otherwise black has
just a draw with queen h2 queen f4 queen
c4
etc just checking that king around out
of its mind
so this very deep nuance has made him
look and look and look
but unfortunately he never saw rook e5
and the follow-up rook h5 otherwise he
never would have looked at this line at
all
he would have simply gone for that so
that's again the difficulty in chess
this ending you guys have already shown
the nuances
there's still some slight chances for
white i don't think that giri thinks
he's out of the woods by
any means is not going to be a quick
finish this game is going to be a while
but
but what is he thinking about is he
actually considering like taking on a
three
some maniacal move like that like what
is he thinking about here that even
legal i guess it is legal i would have
taken that queen on d6 the moment it
landed
exactly uh queen takes a3 rook
e7 this just looks way
way way absurdly dangerous yeah this is
just too much right
yeah from from from to for black to
allow this
uh rook to c8 i would
absolutely say he's looking at this line
he must be right because what else can i
possibly be looking at
and i think that again geary wants to
win the game
he's been playing with risk he's been
playing a bit crazy over the top
over the edge he survived dodged
bullets like neo in the matrix i mean
he's like whoa you're still alive dude
the
guy has the fact that he's still sitting
here and
not having already resigned is something
huge
for him and he's thinking when you mess
up i might be able to take some chances
as long
as i'm not dead lost this is dangerous
but is it over
it it no doubt is but giri has to look
at it because the other ending is not
something he wants to suffer
so yes i think he has a right to look at
that move and then forget about whether
it's dangerous
is it lost danger is one thing in chess
but are you losing are you much worse
what's the real issue specifically in
the position
and if you can't find a knockout punch
guys then gary might think
let's play the move yeah but when you
when do you ever win this position with
black
right no no good thing you get out for
petrol
yeah exactly i'm thinking queen takes
a3 just runs into rookie 7 and then
after
rook to c8 it took me a while because i
actually wanted to play the move
rook f1 because i wanted to come down
but uh rook b1 that's the problem that
anisha is facing he's played the same
move he has taken
on d6 he hasn't realized he couldn't
take those chances yeah exactly
it was too bad right and we are in this
actually double-edged sharp ending
i mean i like white i like white as well
um
there will be some action because the
c-pawn is powerful
and i have a feeling that it's going to
come down to a little bit of a pawn race
because
white should take on f7 i don't think
that black can hold this pawn
no and the only way to prevent black
from losing will be
well c4 c3 c2 and he has played by the
way
king to b7 after queen takes d6
it's a way to avoid the rook trade
exactly exactly he had to
step away from the rook d8 move
but here's our problem right we're going
to play
rook to the seventh attacking this pawn
on f7
or or rook f1 maybe just to keep the
king c8 nuance with the rook trade yeah
yeah
to defend the so there was no trade at
the end huh
yeah to defend the d8 square would have
given black a chance to just play c4 for
example and get going
right there you go and c8 that explains
it there you go there you go
okay well as these players uh
contemplate that double rook ending
let's just thank you for showing us this
all right
yes let's go back to the gearing game
what is this
why are they still blank oh they can't
offer draws
ah okay that's fine they're gonna
explain that i figured it out right
they'll find a repetition they'll find a
repetition at some point all right
and we have more moves no this is wesley
yeah this is wesley uh they're bound to
find some kind of repetition soon that
game is completely locked up
uh yeah it's coming just about now
is that is that it i do believe we're
seeing some kind of a
repetition not a fight night went back
to b3 so if he plays bishop
g1 as long as there's no trade yeah i
think the players are actually looking
uh at one another as well as the arbiter
what can we do
yes let us out of this position and we
have just seen the move
bishop to e3 not bishop to g1
bishop to e3 he's so maybe wesley by the
way is setting a trap
just when your opponent is uh
been moving back and forth and doing
nothing he's just playing for
potentially bishop c1 have you ever been
victimized by that
i don't even think that's a threat i
understand
i think that if you go knight a5 i don't
think bishop c1 actually does anything
you're not threatening to take the pawn
really because i think i i think i might
be somebody
that would be gross i mean i i mean i
yeah i think you just go knight b7
okay and i still don't think you have
anything
and you just keep checking right on d8
oh geez i see what maybe maybe i started
thinking
who is trapping whom this has happened
to me where somebody
declined a repetition to set up a trap
yeah and you failed
happily
[Laughter]
nice uh rook f6 by the way on the board
um
uh intriguing move because again i just
i
i love uh tying up my opponent
is it is this time is it time to see
c4 a5
on camera as as the the move was played
rook f6
and rook to a seven i was very curious
about this because on normal
circumstances you don't want to trade
the rooks the difference in this case is
that if you play rook d7 and i just push
him
are you in time as white to catch the
pawns
talking about some crazy line like this
no i mean because he's played the move
rook h7 right enticing rook f1
so rook d7 rook h uh yeah rook f6 work
h7 let's say rook d7
yes and i just start start going a5
a5 yeah i would like to have the pawns
a and b i think because it's just
farther away than the king
so sorry so if i go king f2 what you're
saying is you want to make
two past pawns but you would like to see
these pawns right because i think if you
think the
a pawn the c pawn is too close to white
it's
king that white's king would be
the blockader and having to cross an
extra rank
right and by the way this again
it feels incredibly dangerous for black
right here it looks like his pieces are
just getting really
and worked out see some kind of race we
have to move rook d7 on the board
he's immediately pushed upon b4 this
is sharp they will get an extra 30
minutes
in just four more moves but they have to
make those moves
the question is can i take on b4 take on
b4 that will be an extra move for both
sides
yes uh can i take on f7
and let's just play the race right yeah
we have to play the race a5 i don't
think you can play b3 because rook f3
just wins the pawn
yes that's a very important point i mean
you can't
just half the pawn go too far away from
both king
and knight uh which is why we started
with the move a5
and then i guess the question we wanted
to ask
should we have our key why not right
should we bring our king shall we but
the problem is
is now b3 and the race may be
in blacksmith winning yeah yeah that's
the problem
so that was found a variation where one
yeah yeah i think that after takes take
i would go
king f2 oh and we do have a result as
a wesley so very expectedly drew against
chakraman medyarov
uh they tried to shake but yeah it's
like the awkward 2021 right
are we there yet with the handshakes are
we not there yet
well it was like the dutch prime
minister earlier in the covid who was
saying you know please don't shake hands
use the elbows and you did it on stage
with somebody else a spokesman for the
government
and they shook hands it was just too
natural i mean
it's a natural thing so let's go back to
the game because it's getting sharp it's
getting exciting both players down to
six minutes
exactly plenty to calculate he's taking
a before c takes before so three moves
to make for both sides
taking on f7 is very natural you could
start by putting the king on f2 and
running it
i think king f2 would uh get my
attention because i just
you know the king is such a great
blockader
of a past pawns especially a connected
past pawns you put a king on b3
and those connected pass pawns go go
nowhere in the meanwhile
by the way these rooks are doing a
fantastic job at
containing both king and knights king f2
a5 see the thing about a5 hold on
the thing about a5 before we go too much
into this variation
a5 rook f5 a5
pardon me so we go king f2
a5 rook f5 yeah because i wanted to
remind you that your knight is pinned do
you give me a chance to get out
of the pin though um
alejandro or you're you're trying to
just win my podcast i'm just trying
your pawns i just i'm not sure that i
can but if i play rook d4 do i actually
just win them
maybe that's the problem
still have knight b5 perhaps no but
knight before i have rook d
d5 as well as rook c4 and rook c5 yes
yes
i understand what you mean okay good
question
um i would have just i was playing king
f2 to
to bring my king over which is not a bad
idea right if you're wrong doesn't work
you can certainly consider king 2 might
be a very strong move
right i'm waiting i'm waiting for you to
play the move king c8 and then forcing
me to play rook takes f7
right so i was just bringing my king
over to the king side
for queenside first and that just by the
way i just want to say that
that to my mind this feels winning for
white because if i ever get a position
where
the pawns are just stuck right yeah
that's
so easy yeah yeah i agree with you
this game gets too close and you get
stuck you're right
uh eventually pick up the g2 pawn
somehow
like maybe like rook g7 or something
rook g7 i play g4
and then you have some like take and
then rook c44
then right and you're in you're in time
to defend
good point okay that is
maurice sharp double-edged
yeah indeed and looking at the engine
evaluation and saying that it is
just fine for black wow
i'd be nervous yeah
yeah so it's fine for black actually
yeah actually there's
just flow through some variations saying
it's fine for black
i'm sure from an emotional standpoint as
gary he's got to be a bit
worried in this position because he
might drop one of those pawns and then
it'll be all she wrote
so it's great that the engine will say
one thing but again the human factor
plays such a big role and he's got to
calculate with
just minutes left on his clock he's got
four minutes
and 49 seconds left uh
to make his move and he's played a5 and
he did play a5 and now
his opponent with five minutes he's got
three moves no
cam that two moves now to time control
so
not horrible time pressure but big
decisions yet to be made and i think
geary realizes
that he's got great counter play he's
got some chances those rooks
look like they're hovering menacingly
but
black is supposed to still be okay
because that b4 pawn
it's pretty fast going down the board
and timing wise you've got to get
everything right as well
with white so help me out here though
maurice after
a5 king e3 how does the computer
uh hold the position because i'm just
i'm just thinking that my king is going
to get over to the queen side
to uh to contain the the two pawns and
then one day i'm going to play rook f7
right uh the engine it's it's loading
right now but i remembered it playing
rook h5
and right now literally ignoring it's
headed over
to making its pawn go down the board so
either
controlling on c5 keeping your king out
or maybe potentially playing for rook b5
just in case
the timing is right but bringing the
rook over into this sector
and then getting down the board this way
that's a bit of a wild
idea but it doesn't look like you have
anything if you play rook takes
on f7 then simply rook to c5 now and
the race begins g4 uh g5 is contained
rook c3 is possible b3 will be a threat
and one of your works will have to come
back to deal with these pawns
and they're going down pretty fast so
black actually has a construction
that stops the game from just ending
uh in a bad way for him these pawns are
fast they're no no that's very close
this part is still back on g2 what
didn't it start crashing through easily
i i got seduced uh when black played the
move rook h7 i thought
right that's not that's the rocket stop
and then when you play rook h5 and you
just allow rook f7 but i understand
you completely the rook on c5 uh
cuts the white king away from the queen
side i think it's such an instructive
move we've seen the move king e2 let's
make sure that we keep
that board on cannot miss the action
here
will he find is i wonder if you still
play the move rookie track
here although on king 2 i was wondering
if you can go uh rook g7 which is far
more natural which is armored
as well yeah yeah there are a lot of
moves to block black is perfectly safe
yeah well i i saw the king e2 rook g7
and i thought well then king e3 of
course but rook
h5 nice
i that was not on my radar and i assume
in rook h5 is still fine if he plays
this rookie five is also fine black is
just happens to have
two damn good pawns are amazing
and they're fast and they're going down
the board uh with alacrity
it's uh it's one move to time control
well two for geary one for
dak so we know funny things
happen from a psychological perspective
right at this moment just when you get
through
move 40 and 41. moves 40 and most 41
two of the most precarious moves in all
of tournament chess
we all have had the experiences right at
that moment
when you were alive oh i made it to time
control blunder whoa what just happened
all right so let's pay attention to that
as well he's going for the rook and i
think
all of the ideas of moving the rook were
good
by the way with a little little twist
yeah you think
i think he finally is like yes this is a
draw i'm not in danger
i see it kind of thing and i i think
it's pretty clear you don't want to play
king f2 as white that just makes no
sense
right you kind of have to take on f7 to
really create any threats
by the way i have to allow you for the
whole
a5 b4 what you wanted because
if the pawn were on c5 you would never
gotten to play rook h5
and rook to c5 but with the pawn on a5
you've kept the c5 bacon so that
you intuited it it very nicely by the
way rook
g7 if i take the pawn
that's already on the board he's played
the move king d1 i think you're just
perpetual right rook g1
king c2 rook g2 if you go to b3 i'll
give you another check on uh g3 and the
problem is you can't go to a4
that's just mate that'd be sweet
that that's walking into the upper cut
i mean mate
i just did a book called king walks by
the way and i mean the suicide march
hit her the best i mean but if you don't
go to the a4 square if you go to any
other square i'll just put my rook on c3
and then i'll start thinking about how
to win it exactly white has no more
pawns
this position would be a draw even if
you eliminated black's two pawns
probably
as long as the rook gets to defend the
knight
as long as the rook was sitting on c6
and i gifted you
the two pawns it's still a draw so
this one here giri is fully out of
danger and you could tell from his body
language the way he just
not only moved the pieces but the way
he's sitting the way he's holding his
pen right now saying come on
hurry up and make a move and just accept
this draw he's not even getting up
he knows this will be a repetition and
is that upset or something
i don't know why he's upset because
maybe he just realized did he think that
he was potentially winning
well maybe look at that face gary made
like yeah right yeah like what were you
thinking right
the body language of deck makes me think
he thought he was winning that yeah
exactly king b3 maybe you overlooked it
i think he just overlooked that you can
just keep checking i don't know what he
overlooked
but because even even king a4 and i
don't have checkmate right here
c3 still still a draw that's exactly
right and what look i mean
look at him he's demonstrating feels
like uh he's disappointed deeply
disappointed
i mean even if i didn't have this like
you can just toss upon it as long as i
get my rook to the c file
right no it's a draw to draw clearly
now nothing like we said without the
pawns and
geary i will tell you what gear he's
thinking gary's thinking i played like a
dummy in this [ __ ] like why was it what
was i
doing in this game seriously giri will
be kicking himself
for playing such crappy chess and
thinking okay i made it out but
come on i can't keep playing like this
if i'm going to win the tournament just
yeah
you just can't keep doing that on the
other hand get off get away
i didn't like his moves but i liked his
opening approach
i like that he puts himself out there
that he try something new
the anti-moscow is not part of gary's
repertoire as far as i'm concerned
and it's very sharp he brought in a new
idea with knight a6
yes he fumbled it there's no question
about this move g4 was absolutely
terrible
um but he came in with the black pieces
saying
look you're a 2600 gm i'm a niche geary
let me try to beat you i don't care
black black yeah
it's an approach that we didn't see from
the other players aronian playing
against lupulescu
he was just very happy to take a draw
lupulisco also happy to take a draw
i like that he brought the attitude
absolutely
i did too and it what was shocking is
how straightforward
uh anish played this position because uh
obviously he's an exchange down and this
knight on a6
is offsides so you put it on d5 and then
you force the action
uh by playing g4 right away and opening
up the position by the way
what's really fascinating for me is the
computer thinks this is the
third best move in the position vision
takes g4
sorry to interrupt you as we're seeing
facial expressions now from the players
indicating draw is coming
and he's played the repetition right
there uh as we see
and anish may be doing it one more time
to be sure
but it looks like they're starting to uh
write down
the draw so that there's no issues
and there we go four full repetition
yeah just to be sure
to be sure that was done yeah and that's
it time for
looks like either a handshake there it
is they're comfortable with right there
and that's done five draws
for the round but this one all of
romania will be saying oh man you had
him
i want to see if he tells him about
rookie five right now they're talking
but anisha hasn't pointed out rookie
five on the square yet
yeah he's mentioning king c8 instead of
king b8 maybe
tweet all right he's
talking about king b7 e3 looked like he
mentioned right there
yeah but what about king c8 might have
been a little bit better maybe i could
have won
stop it but come on what about rookie
five did anish himself see it
he hasn't pointed to the e5 square as
yet well he's just
pointed to the c5 when he played the
move c5
uh i was stunned i was stunned i mean
like what
really but it was a good resource i
think that he was running out of ideas
true that that position was already
quite bad yes
it it clearly it it had gone south
we haven't seen any reaction either if
he had told him
you would think that bogdan by now would
have said
oh yeah i had rookie five right we
haven't seen any disappointment yet
and he's shocked i just don't think i
need star rook h5
so maybe anish actually didn't see the
win yeah
yeah i think that will be a stunner to
both players
if it's pointed out uh before they again
we'll
we'll stay with the show for a little
bit and see if we can't get uh
the players to join uh either elmira or
christian
in uh and we did not see anything in
that analysis that
the thing indicated like five rook h5
big moment
yeah you missed a big moment indeed
a lot of hidden drama in chess that's
what makes the graves
the game so great what didn't happen
is often as uh profound and dramatic
as what did and the effect it could
potentially have
on the players knowing that this was
possible
yeah yeah and this is what our day
looked at it's round one
ten ten way tie for first then wait time
for first that's what happens
uh i'm wondering how they ordered this
one
but luke will escape there you go at the
top at the top uh
well all draws half a point for every
single one of these players
uh we'll have to try again tomorrow guys
not very exciting to start with five
draws
particularly three of them in case of a
10 player tie break what is the
tiebreaker format
they just say forget about it we're
going to paris
i'll take a look at tomorrow's tomorrow
is
certainly will be more exciting
hopefully
hopefully june 6 don't forget same time
same place will be round two and let's
take
a look at what's in store for tomorrow
we have the pairings
made up coming up eventually eventually
the pairing is coming up
we promise it's almost there no not just
kidding
just kidding just this is keeping you on
the edge of your seats there
but all right things about uh this round
all right let me mention at the very
start a lot of the top players were
black
yeah a lot of the top players were black
the bearings tomorrow wesley saw will
play
against lavon aronian that's a game
fabiano caruana with the white pieces
this guy is going to definitely try to
win he's going to be playing against
constantine lupulescu okay
anish giri with white he'll be trying to
play beat
te mu rajabov another player with the
white piece is much higher rated let's
see if he can do
the job or is that going to come again
with a surprise and be the one
pushing mvl will be playing against that
and
last but certainly not least always
producing exciting games
chakra yarmadiarov will be playing
against
alexander christchurch nice it's a great
that's a good parents i like the
pairings i'd like to see some
yes we know that at least two of these
players are going to say
uh hello i am top 10 in the world right
you are the local
exactly yeah exactly and
you know what you bleed rating points
with these drawers as well i mean okay
you know yeah eating them but a little
bit of points
that you gotta throw out i just lost my
rating one no no
no i gotta beat you so uh that we expect
to see some belligerence
today was not it today it looks like
they were just back and kind of feeling
themselves
back in tournament chess how many
professional players have had this long
uh
hiatus since maybe world war
ii world war ii right i mean
right where the players just didn't get
a chance to get a chance to play i mean
i don't i can't think of any other
period in chess history
where chess was just shut down for a
long period of time i think we're
literally going back to world war
ii and now the player is making history
this century
playing uh again finally and
let us get to one of those players as
christian
has a niche in bucharest
thank you maurice yes i'm here with uh
anish giri who had a very uh
tense uh game in round one against the
youngster
uh dak anish take us a little bit
through the game also tell us a little
bit
about your strategy going into this game
you're playing the lowest rated uh
player in the event
did you want to complicate matters and
just go for the kill
well keel is a strong award but uh yeah
i wanted to
to try to play as we had seen very early
on in the round um
the way it was on my shoulders i had to
carry this tournament forward there was
nobody else wanted to place us
so um yeah i made sure there is some
excitement after 95 rupee one
uh well i was knight h5 prepared yeah
it's a theory and here the variation
goes knight d7 d5
and then i remember what was going on
there and then if i wanted i would make
sure you have nothing to talk about
today at all because this line
is a fourth draw but uh there is also
this option of takes in 96
that is actually a little risky but it's
quite playable and i thought today is a
perfect opportunity to
to take that risk because uh okay i am
higher rated on my opponent and
you know you should take risks and
should probably work out but um
it was not so simple uh i didn't really
recall the details i think a3 is an okay
move if i'm not mistaken
but here already i was on my well i
couldn't recall the details but i
i was very happy with the with my
position i thought the huge mistake i
made was here
um oh i see computer gives advantage to
white i didn't think that way very often
when you play um
when you have an ambitious mindset you
start to overestimate every single
balance
imbalance that is in your favor so as
long as there is some imbalance you
always think that well you're on the
good side of things so that was the case
here today
as well and um i realized h4 is a huge
mistake but
i didn't access i mean i thought um 95
i'm better maybe why didn't you want to
play knight c5 it feels like wow
i can't say i wanted to include h4g4 and
deploy 95.
and i didn't at all allow thought that
my opponent can um somehow
because this diagonal c5 g1 is very weak
and somehow i had some
some kind of flash that you know i go a
gfg the queen gets to c5 he goes queen
of two i go to question
i mean this kind of i mean let's say
something along the lines of uh
i didn't really see b3 like something
along the lines of suicidal
line like that sort of went through my
head and i thought okay oh great but of
course
upon closer closer examination i
realized that after he bc perhaps i'm
completely lost so
let's uh and then i realized what i've
done it was a disaster i mean
of course 95 first or h4g45 the
difference was very small
but i was somehow yeah i mean i i was
thinking here about h3 first
which is very interesting and then i
decided that well maybe i will go knight
c5 so i thought that i will take the
decision
move later so the h4 is a good thing to
include but then yeah i realized that i
mean i thought
to be honest i i don't know i see this
particular engine here gives white
advantage
i thought during the game that i am
comfortable i didn't feel like
white has an advantage from our
perspective i mean i saw this kind of
stuff
when he goes uh before night uh root d3
i just
didn't i just thought that he has good
drawing chances i didn't okay i see here
why it's better i just thought i'm a
pawn up and
the best that can happen is that we make
some sort of draw but i see that yeah
actually position is probably drawn and
i should probably be precise
um but yeah i i missed b3 and one
question
one question before we jump to uh too
many conclusions
after queen the six c five did you see
the move rookie five
no i didn't
but you know i um i mean i felt to be
honest already here
i could i'm this bad yeah i couldn't
believe it i felt i shouldn't be like
here
i shouldn't be so bad my original plan
was queen g5 queen c3 and queen c5
but then i realized that after takes
takes rookie 5 y is on the good side of
the end game
and at this point i was still assessing
position wrongly i mean
of course compared to what i got in the
game this is better also i see now that
y doesn't even have to go for the end
game
i thought yeah this is too hard this
king of one could i give a check can you
two okay
yeah i should have done this anyway so
the thing is i was i had the estimation
of the position wrong i thought black
should be
should be fine and then whenever i saw a
position where i'm slightly worse
i dismissed it and i thought that's this
is not the way to go and i realized um
far too late that i'm in trouble and
here already yeah i mean
queen g7 is such a yeah it's a sad move
i thought to include g4 but yeah g4 was
good
and the way he played i was kind of
happy with c5 because i didn't see
um how he wins on the spot i mean this
tactic
was above me obviously and um
i thought if there is no direct win you
know positionally it's good to trade
this ugly bishop right positionally it's
not so bad and so i thought maybe i'm
okay
and we felt that rookie five might be
the move that he's going to make just
because
it feels like the only move in the
position unless you see this whole thing
that he did in the game
with queen d7 and rook takes c6 because
otherwise i mean i i think that
uh no you consider rookie five you see
h3 and then you can bail out with rook
takes c5 that's the thing
you can just take on c5 and bail out
that's why we thought that
that's what i expected yeah yeah oh and
then he would hear notice rakesh five
right right oh that's uh yeah i see life
yeah it's not always as you think life
you know sometimes you think one thing
will happen
uh but then unpredictable things you
know she says no and so on yeah
okay so c5 i thought it was very cool i
i thought at first this is completely
strange and then i saw this quiz six
queen d6 idea
and then um yeah then he's still in the
driver's seat
um i think i was am i okay
i'm okay yeah it seems like you're fine
oh i'm okay here if k3
b3 oh i'm okay okay that's not a big
deal at all
if i'm okay here it's fine how do you
feel about uh the result
the result is it's not about results to
be honest
you know when whenever they speak about
classical chess and death and so on
for everyone and the problem in chess is
that you've got results and you've got
also
content you know it's a content creator
right of course you know what it is
content
like um as long as there's content on
the board it's okay
but so i yeah i mean
to be honest he played okay and i was
never in danger of winning this game so
uh i think to be honest he's pretty from
what i saw today it's pretty good i mean
i think
he's a very solid player he's a pretty
good player it was hard for me to assess
of course he's not bad anyway but um
i didn't know because i was preparing
and so many games are from some online
tournaments
not even the big ones so from some small
bliss tournaments
and it's very hard to make a good
picture because okay if you see these
blitz games he plays quite poorly but
then i see my blizz games i also play
poorly
there was not enough data to go through
i know he's talented but i didn't know
how
good he is what kind of risk i should
take so yeah i thought i should take
some risk because you never know maybe
later he will collapse and i'll be the
stupid one you know who didn't take
the opportunity so i tried to play but
from what i saw today
he played well so i don't think i
deserved to win at all and at some point
i was even worried um so i think draw is
good
and again i mean i'm happy with um you
know as long as i do my best i enjoy
life i play chess
i'm happy um so yeah results of course i
want to win but
they can't always that's a very precise
assessment about the dag and his
capabilities and
the result in itself uh what are your
ambitions for the tournament
i know we're only in round one yeah
first place but uh
early to speak because no it's not easy
uh
very very strong tight fields also many
of players
you maybe took okay today maybe first
round but um well very solid games
everywhere
so some players for some reason didn't
even want to
to fight so yeah you'll we'll see maybe
things will
get warmed up fabiano is a great fighter
he will definitely
if something he'll start to steer the
drama so i think it's going to get
exciting but
um let's see let's see a lot of solid
players well a draw and some content for
the fans
yes content thank you anish and uh good
luck in the rest of our game thank you
guys back to you thank you christian
carrying the round and carrying the
conversation
that's not wrong he's not wrong he's not
wrong at all
maurice final thoughts please yes indeed
very entertaining stuff there from
anishi always
brings it and he showed something
of a bias that i talk about with
corporate talks
and that is confirmation bias where you
see what you expect to see
even when facts are saying otherwise and
as far as anish is concerned he thought
black was okay
black was always okay so no matter what
move got on the board he said
i'm just fine everything's good and i
can play whatever i want
when in fact the moves were saying
otherwise
and so he was very very fortunate that
his bias actually worked out
the strength of his belief turned out to
be enough to save
the game indeed he was that game in fact
was the one that carried
the round carried our interest the
players started off
very slowly in tepid fashion very
careful
with their comeback to the tour i expect
to see different tomorrow
as the higher rated players start to get
white we should see a lot more action
like this game should be fun and let's
hope it is because we're looking forward
to seeing
a lot of action and we are now going to
get some thoughts
from our players
in our comments fellow commentators in
romania
thank you maurice uh yes i mean what an
amazing
day of chess okay let's not sugarcoat it
three of those five games
were not very combative but at least we
got this one
and uh anish definitely showed us how
spectacular
his uh style can be at times we've seen
we've gathered some information about
dak
as well he's definitely managed to uh
keep his nerves
in check okay he missed rookie five but
rookie five is not an easy move uh to
see
nevertheless he didn't go into time
trouble he uh was confident enough
to keep his cool and he managed to make
a draw some very interesting information
alira what did you think about the first
round well
we could call this a round of a
observation but still i was pretty
impressed by
doug's game i think that he was very
well prepared and also anishkiri was
ready to take risks in this game so we
had a very interesting battle so it's
our
david against goliath yes game so i'm
actually sad you know i was expecting
jack to win so
this is how legends are created yes we
needed it for romanian public
so i really hope that he will gain some
confidence after this game
and play in this manner like later on
and i think that's a very good point
gain some confidence and not lose
confidence
when he sees that rook e5 that was on
the board of course and
what is interesting about it is like
when i was listening to gary caspar this
was such a passionate analysis because
he was he wanted to know more he wanted
to wait for another move and another
move that means that the position was so
complicated
and you mentioned that this rook e5 was
not obvious
it's not about computer analysis it's
about the idea
if you know that you have to find this
idea and when anish mentioned that he
didn't want to play knight c5 first and
include h4 and g4
basically you know that you have to
fight against dispositional idea b3 he
knew this but
you know he maybe lost track of the game
at that point and
that's gave jack advantage of the game
it was a very interesting battle
absolutely a very interesting start uh
this is only day one so
there's a lot of excitement in store for
us and
we're looking forward to the next rounds
guys back to you in st
louis thank you elmira thank you kristen
just want to say it was great to be back
in studio with you both
alejandro maurice it's always a pleasure
and i'll look forward to tomorrow thank
you all for joining us
we'll see you tomorrow more exciting
games than today
i guarantee it i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
you